This holiday season, give your loved ones only the best from L.L.Bean. Let them wrap themselves in L.L.Bean's wide variety of sweaters. Choose from L.L.Bean's classics like their rag wool and cotton fisherman sweaters. Crafted with exceptional materials like lamb's wool and premium cotton, they're the perfect way to stay cozy and warm all winter. Give only the best gifts from L.L. Bean at Oakville Place, Georgian Mall & Berry, and CF shops at Don Mills. Hey Torontonians, recycling is more than a routine.
在这个节日季，请将 L.L.Bean 最好的产品送给您挚爱的人。让他们穿上 L.L.Bean 种类繁多的毛衣，尽享温暖。您可以选择 L.L.Bean 的经典款式，如粗纺羊毛毛衣和棉质渔夫毛衣。它们采用羔羊毛和优质棉等卓越材质精心制作，是整个冬季保持舒适温暖的完美之选。请前往 Oakville Place、Georgian Mall & Berry 以及 CF Shops at Don Mills 的 L.L.Bean 门店，选购最棒的节日礼物。嘿，多伦多人们，回收利用不仅仅是一种日常习惯。
It's a vital responsibility. By recycling properly, you help conserve resources, reduce energy use and greenhouse gas emissions, and protect the environment. Toronto's Blue Bin Recycling Program ensures the majority of the right items are recovered and transformed into new products. Recycling right is important and impactful. Let's work together and make a difference because small actions lead to big change. For more tips on recycling
这是一项至关重要的责任。通过正确回收，您可以帮助节约资源、减少能源消耗和温室气体排放，并保护环境。多伦多的蓝色回收箱计划确保了大部分可回收物品都能被回收并转化为新产品。正确回收既重要又具有影响力。让我们携手合作，做出改变，因为微小的行动也能带来巨大的变化。获取更多回收建议，请
visit toronto.ca slash recycle right. Some stories are so profound, so unimaginable that they stay with us forever. The Unthinkable is the latest podcast from Casefile Presents, hosted by two of Australia's leading voices in true crime, Vicky Petratus and Emily Webb. The series delves into tales of ordinary people who have faced extraordinary, often devastating events and emerged forever changed. From survivors of traumatic events to victims of relentless stalking and even those who've confronted some of Australia's most notorious criminals, The Unthinkable explores the depths of human resilience.
访问 toronto.ca/recycle-right。有些故事是如此深刻，如此难以想象，以至于它们永远留在我们心中。《The Unthinkable》是 Casefile Presents 推出的最新播客，由澳大利亚两位顶尖的真实犯罪节目主持人 Vicky Petratus 和 Emily Webb 主持。该系列深入探讨了普通人面对非同寻常、往往是毁灭性事件并从此彻底改变的故事。从创伤事件的幸存者到无情跟踪的受害者，甚至那些面对过澳大利亚最臭名昭著罪犯的人，《The Unthinkable》探索了人类韧性的深度。
The first two episodes feature the incredible story of Louisa Hope, a woman who survived Sydney's Lindt Cafe siege in 2014. Both episodes will be available for free on Sunday November 10 wherever you get your podcasts, with episodes dropping weekly after that. Be sure to follow The Unthinkable so you don't miss an episode. Stay tuned until the end of today's episode to hear the trailer. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website.
前两集讲述了路易莎·霍普（Louisa Hope）的不可思议的故事，她是在 2014 年悉尼林特咖啡馆人质劫持事件中幸存下来的女性。这两集将于 11 月 10 日星期日免费发布，您可以在任何收听播客的平台上收听，之后每周更新一集。请务必关注《The Unthinkable》，以免错过任何一集。请收听今天节目的结尾，以获取预告片。我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用程序或我们网站上本集的节目说明。
It was cold and dreary as Josefina Rivera made her way down 6th Street in North Philadelphia on the night of Wednesday November 26 1986. It had been a difficult year for the 25-year-old who had lost custody of her three young children due to her ongoing struggles with the drug addiction. With the new year just around the corner, Josefina was determined to make some positive changes. Her social worker had promised that if she could find a job and a stable home, she'd have a chance at getting her kids back. Needing money to secure an apartment, Josefina had turned to sex work. She was in the process of getting off drugs and making her new home just right so her social worker could see just how serious she was about regaining custody of her children. The following day was Thanksgiving.
1986 年 11 月 26 日星期三晚上，北费城的第六街寒冷而阴沉。对于 25 岁的约瑟芬娜·里维拉（Josefina Rivera）来说，这是艰难的一年，由于她长期与毒瘾作斗争，她失去了三个年幼孩子的监护权。随着新年的临近，约瑟芬娜决心做出一些积极的改变。她的社会工作者承诺，如果她能找到一份工作并拥有一个稳定的家，她就有机会夺回孩子的监护权。为了筹集租房资金，约瑟芬娜开始从事性工作。她正在努力戒毒，并把新家布置得井井有条，好让社会工作者看到她夺回孩子监护权的决心。第二天就是感恩节。
Josefina intended to make a nice dinner, so she headed out with the hopes of doing a quick job or two so that she'd have some extra cash. She typically found it easy to find willing customers, but being a holiday, the streets were quiet. Josefina couldn't help but notice that one particular vehicle had driven by her a couple of times. It was a brand new Cadillac Coupe de Ville, the expensive car standing out in the rough and under-resourced neighbourhood. Eventually, the Cadillac pulled over. The driver, a white middle-aged male, rolled down his window and asked Josefina if she was working. She responded that she was. The two negotiated a price and Josefina got into the passenger seat. The man introduced himself as Gary and said he just had to make a quick stop first.
约瑟芬娜打算做一顿丰盛的晚餐，于是她出门希望能快速做一两单生意，赚点外快。她通常很容易找到愿意交易的顾客，但由于是节假日，街道上很冷清。约瑟芬娜不禁注意到，有一辆车在她身边经过了好几次。那是一辆崭新的凯迪拉克 Coupe de Ville，这辆昂贵的车在贫困且资源匮乏的社区显得格外显眼。最终，凯迪拉克靠边停了下来。司机是一名中年白人男子，他摇下车窗问约瑟芬娜是否在工作。她回答说是。两人谈妥了价格，约瑟芬娜坐进了副驾驶座。那名男子自称加里（Gary），并说他得先去办点急事。
The two drove along the quiet streets, giving Josefina the chance to clock a proper look at Gary. There was nothing particularly remarkable about him. He was of slim build, about six foot tall, relatively clean cut, but with scruffy dark hair and a full beard. He wore jeans and a shabby cowhide jacket with fringing down the arms, both of which had visible stains on them. In direct contrast to his somewhat unkempt appearance, Josefina noticed a genuine gold chain around his neck and an expensive Rolex watch on
两人沿着安静的街道行驶，这让约瑟芬娜有机会仔细打量加里。他并没有什么特别引人注目的地方。他身材瘦削，身高约六英尺，外表相对整洁，但留着凌乱的深色头发和浓密的胡须。他穿着牛仔裤和一件袖子上带有流苏的破旧牛皮夹克，两件衣服上都有明显的污渍。与他有些邋遢的外表形成鲜明对比的是，约瑟芬娜注意到他脖子上戴着一条纯金项链，手腕上戴着一块昂贵的劳力士手表。
his wrist. Gary stopped in at a McDonald's restaurant and grabbed a cup of coffee. Back in the car, he told Josefina he wanted them to go to his house. This was something Josefina didn't typically do. She serviced most of her clients in their own cars or the nearby motels, getting in and out as quickly as she could. But it was a slow night and Gary had offered a decent price. There was also nothing about him that raised any red flags. Just this once, Josefina decided to make an exception. Gary Gary drove a few blocks further north into the 25th district, a predominantly black and Hispanic neighbourhood notorious for drug-related gang violence. He eventually turned down North Marshall Street, a residential block characterised by deteriorating
加里在一家麦当劳停下，买了一杯咖啡。回到车里后，他告诉约瑟芬娜他想带她去他家。这通常是约瑟芬娜不会做的事情。她的大多数客户都是在他们自己的车里或附近的汽车旅馆里接待的，尽量速战速决。但那天晚上生意冷清，而且加里给出的价格还不错。此外，他身上也没有任何让她感到危险的迹象。约瑟芬娜决定破例一次。加里开车向北又走了几个街区，进入了第 25 区，这是一个以毒品相关的帮派暴力而闻名的黑人和西班牙裔社区。他最终转入北马歇尔街，这是一个以破旧的联排房屋为特征的住宅区，大多数房屋有两三层高，并且至少与邻近的建筑共用一面墙。
row houses, most of them two or three storeys high and sharing at least one wall with its neighbouring building. Gary pulled up at 3520 North Marshall Street. It was just like all the others save for a couple of distinct differences. Only one side of Gary's house shared a wall with his neighbour. On the other side was an empty block littered with rubbish. Unlike the surrounding homes, whose front doors opened directly onto the cracked sidewalks, Gary's house was set several feet back, separated from the street by a short chain-link fence. Gary and Josefina got out of the Cadillac and made their way inside.
加里在北马歇尔街 3520 号停了下来。它和其他房子没什么两样，除了几个明显的区别。加里的房子只有一侧与邻居共用墙壁。另一侧是一个堆满垃圾的空地。与周围那些前门直接通向破裂人行道的房屋不同，加里的房子向后退了几英尺，与街道之间隔着一道短铁丝网围栏。加里和约瑟芬娜下了凯迪拉克，走进了屋里。
As Gary unlocked the door, Josefina noticed that the key he used was unlike any she'd ever seen before. She asked about it, and Gary explained that he'd made it himself by sawing the regular key in half so the front part stayed permanently inside the lock. This way, no other key would work except his. Although Josephina thought this was odd, she didn't give it much more thought. The inside of Gary's house was otherwise ordinary, albeit sparsely furnished and relatively untidy. The only unusual detail was that Gary had meticulously glued coins into the walls of his kitchen. In the living room, the window was protected by metal bars, which was typical of the area. The room housed a grubby orange couch,
当加里打开门时，约瑟芬娜注意到他用的钥匙与她以前见过的任何钥匙都不同。她问起这件事，加里解释说这是他自己做的，他把一把普通的钥匙锯成两半，这样前半部分就永久地留在了锁里。这样一来，除了他的钥匙，其他任何钥匙都打不开。虽然约瑟芬娜觉得这很奇怪，但她并没有多想。加里的房子内部看起来很普通，尽管家具稀少且相对杂乱。唯一不寻常的细节是，加里在厨房的墙壁上精心粘贴了硬币。在客厅里，窗户由金属栅栏保护，这在当地很常见。房间里放着一张脏兮兮的橙色沙发、
a couple of arcade games, a television with a video cassette recorder, and a large stack of video cassette tapes. Josefina caught a quick glance of the handwritten titles and could see that many of them were pornographic films. She followed Gary upstairs, noticing that the walls in the hallway were plastered with $1 bills. Every now and then, there was a $20 bill among them. They went into the bedroom and had consensual sex as agreed. Afterwards, as Josefina got up to get dressed, Gary made some strange small talk. On the drive over, Josefina had told Gary that she had three children who were home with a babysitter and she couldn't be out long.
几台街机游戏机、一台带有录像机的电视机，以及一大堆录像带。约瑟芬娜匆匆扫了一眼手写的标题，发现其中许多是色情电影。她跟着加里上楼，注意到走廊的墙上贴满了 1 美元的钞票。偶尔，其中还夹杂着一张 20 美元的钞票。他们走进卧室，按照约定发生了自愿性关系。事后，当约瑟芬娜起身穿衣服时，加里开始进行一些奇怪的闲聊。在开车过来的路上，约瑟芬娜曾告诉加里，她有三个孩子在家里由保姆照看，她不能出来太久。
She'd made up the lie about the babysitter so that Gary wouldn't try to make her stay, but instead it seemed to have sparked his interest. Gary seemed particularly curious about Josefina's fertility, asking if she was still able to have children and probing about whether or not she'd had a hysterectomy. Then, out of nowhere, Gary came up behind Josefina and secured his hands firmly around her neck. Having been lucky enough not to have experienced violence on the job before, Josefina was completely caught off guard. It took her a moment to realise what was happening. Images of her life flashed before her in a way that she described as being like a broken film projector before the reality dawned on her that she was being choked.
她编造了关于保姆的谎言，是为了不让加里强留她，但没想到这反而引起了他的兴趣。加里似乎对约瑟芬娜的生育能力特别好奇，询问她是否还能生育，并探听她是否做过子宫切除手术。然后，毫无征兆地，加里走到约瑟芬娜身后，双手紧紧地掐住了她的脖子。由于以前从未在工作中遇到过暴力，约瑟芬娜完全措手不及。她花了一会儿时间才意识到发生了什么。她生命中的画面像坏掉的电影放映机一样在她眼前闪过，随后她意识到自己正在被掐死。
Gary loosened his grip just as Josefina began to fade into unconsciousness. Coming to, she started struggling against him only to realise that he'd managed to slip a handcuff over her right wrist. Josefina begged Gary not to hurt her, promising to comply with whatever he wanted. Gary remained completely calm and collected. He said he wouldn't hurt her as long as she stood still. He then proceeded to cuff Josephine's hands behind her back and led her back down the stairs. Once they got to the kitchen, Gary opened another door. He led Josephina down a narrow set of steps into a dank, damp basement. It was cold, and the smell of mould filled the air. There was only one small window, more like an air vent, which was covered by a metal flap that blocked any view of the outside
就在约瑟芬娜快要失去知觉时，加里松开了手。恢复意识后，她开始挣扎，却发现他已经成功地给她戴上了一副手铐。约瑟芬娜恳求加里不要伤害她，承诺会配合他想要的一切。加里保持着完全的冷静和镇定。他说只要她保持不动，他就不会伤害她。然后，他把约瑟芬娜的双手铐在背后，带着她走下楼梯。当他们到达厨房时，加里打开了另一扇门。他带着约瑟芬娜走下一段狭窄的台阶，进入了一个阴暗潮湿的地下室。那里很冷，空气中弥漫着霉味。只有一个小窗户，更像是一个通风口，上面覆盖着一个金属盖，挡住了看向外面的视线。
world. A single overhead light bulb illuminated the bleak surroundings, which included a white freezer chest, a washing machine, and a bucket. Various bits of debris littered the concrete floor, while sandbags and insulation had been stacked against the walls as soundproofing. while sandbags and insulation had been stacked against the walls as soundproofing. Scanning the room, Josefina noticed something in the middle of the floor. A section of concrete had been demolished and a hole roughly the size of a small bathtub had been dug out underneath. Wondering what purpose this hole could possibly serve, Josefina was struck with the terrifying thought. Was she looking at her own grave? As Josefina stood there naked, Gary proceeded to secure a metal chain around her ankle using a homemade shackle device he'd fashioned from a muffler clamp, a small metal bar, and a superglue.
一盏悬挂的灯泡照亮了凄凉的环境，其中包括一个白色冰柜、一台洗衣机和一个水桶。混凝土底板上散落着各种碎片，沙袋和隔热材料堆在墙边作为隔音层。约瑟芬娜扫视着房间，注意到地板中间有些东西。一块混凝土被拆除了，下面挖出了一个大约相当于小浴缸大小的洞。约瑟芬娜想知道这个洞到底有什么用，心中涌起一个可怕的念头。她是在看自己的坟墓吗？当约瑟芬娜赤身裸体地站在那里时，加里开始用一个自制的镣铐装置将金属链锁在她的脚踝上，这个装置是他用消音器夹、一根小金属棒和强力胶制成的。
fashioned from a muffler clamp, a small metal bar, and a super glue. Methodically he used a hairdryer to dry the glue before attaching the other end of the chain to a sewer pipe that ran along the ceiling, affixing it with a padlock. This enabled Josefina to move around but only by shuffling her feet and as far as the 12 foot long chain would allow. Gary then shoved Josephina into the hole in the basement floor and covered it up with a piece of plywood. It wasn't until she was in there that she realised just how restrictive it was. Josephina was only 5 foot 6 with a petite frame, but she had to fold her legs against her chest just to fit her whole body inside, and even then she stuck out too much for the plywood to sit completely flat.
他有条不紊地用吹风机吹干胶水，然后将链条的另一端固定在沿着天花板延伸的下水道管上，并用挂锁锁住。这使得约瑟芬娜可以走动，但只能拖着脚走，而且范围仅限于 12 英尺长的链条所允许的距离。随后，加里把约瑟芬娜推进了地下室地板上的洞里，并用一块胶合板盖住。直到被关进去，她才意识到这个空间有多么狭窄。约瑟芬娜身高只有 5 英尺 6 英寸，身材娇小，但她必须把腿折叠在胸前才能把整个身体塞进去，即便如此，她还是露出了太多，导致胶合板无法完全平整地盖上。
To hold it down, Gary secured it by placing a couple of bags of dirt on top. Josephina could barely breathe. Panic gripped her body as she tried to comprehend what was happening. How long did Gary intend to keep her in the hole? Would he even let her out at all? Certain she'd run out of air, Josefina sobbed and begged for mercy as her arms started going numb. She screamed for what felt like hours, even though she knew there was no point. Gary had set his radio to a local rock station and was blasting it as loud as it would go. Josephina knew right away this wasn't to keep her entertained. It was to drown out the sound of her screams.
为了压住它，加里在上面放了几个土袋。约瑟芬娜几乎无法呼吸。恐慌笼罩着她的身体，她试图理解正在发生的事情。加里打算把她关在洞里多久？他甚至会放她出来吗？约瑟芬娜确信自己会窒息而死，她啜泣着乞求怜悯，手臂开始发麻。她尖叫了几个小时，尽管她知道这毫无意义。加里把收音机调到了当地的一个摇滚电台，并把音量开到最大。约瑟芬娜立刻明白，这并不是为了让她娱乐，而是为了掩盖她的尖叫声。
Hour after hour ticked by as Josefina endured the extreme pain and discomfort of being stuck in the hole while also battling hunger, exhaustion, and emotional distress. Her voice cracked and ached from her constant screaming. It was pitch black, but she was able to keep track of time thanks to the radio announcements. Twenty hours passed by before Josefina heard footsteps. Suddenly, her vision was flooded with light as the plywood lid was ripped off the hole. Gary was back in the basement. In his hand was a large stick. He leant into the hole and began beating Josefina with it, grabbing her by the hair and administering blow after painful blow while repeatedly telling her to shut up. Josefina did as she was told, shocked by the brutality of Gary's actions.
时间一小时一小时地过去，约瑟芬娜忍受着被困在洞里的极度痛苦和不适，同时还要与饥饿、疲惫和精神折磨作斗争。她的嗓子因为不断的尖叫而沙哑疼痛。虽然漆黑一片，但多亏了收音机的广播，她还能记录时间。二十个小时过去了，约瑟芬娜听到了脚步声。突然，随着胶合板盖子被掀开，光线涌入洞中。加里回到了地下室。他手里拿着一根大棍子。他探进洞里，开始用棍子殴打约瑟芬娜，抓住她的头发，一边反复叫她闭嘴，一边施加痛苦的打击。约瑟芬娜照做了，被加里的残暴行为震惊了。
Gary then shoved her back into the hole and replaced the plywood lid before disappearing back upstairs. He returned about 30 minutes later with a glass of water, ordering Josefina to get out of the hole and onto an air mattress which had been pushed into the corner of the room. He removed her handcuffs and gave her the water, which she drank thirstily, before Gary proceeded to rape her., Gary laid down beside her and fell asleep. While he slept, she looked around for possible ways to escape, but she knew it was no use. Gary hadn't brought the keys to the padlock with him, so there was no way she was getting out of her chains. she was getting out of her chains. Then, Gary woke up with a start. He immediately hopped up, grabbed a shovel, and got to work widening the hole on the basement floor. As he worked,
加里随后把她推回洞里，盖上胶合板，然后消失在楼上。大约 30 分钟后，他带着一杯水回来，命令约瑟芬娜从洞里出来，躺到角落里的充气床垫上。他解开了她的手铐，给了她水，她贪婪地喝了下去，随后加里强奸了她。加里躺在她身边睡着了。在他睡觉时，她环顾四周寻找逃跑的方法，但她知道没用。加里没有带挂锁的钥匙，所以她根本无法摆脱锁链。这时，加里惊醒了。他立刻跳起来，拿起一把铲子，开始加宽地下室地板上的洞。在他工作时，
he chatted candidly to Josefina, telling her that his one dream in life was to raise a big family. He explained that he'd fathered four different children to four different women, but each time the authorities had taken the children away and he never got to see them again. He spoke with the disdain about protective services and the government in general, explaining that he used to work as a medic for the army until they began dosing him with hallucinogenic drugs without his consent. Gary told Josefina, quote, I went to the doctors with a medical complaint and by the time they finished treating me, I was out of my fucking mind. He said he was discharged from the military and had been in and out of mental health facilities
他坦率地与约瑟芬娜聊天，说他人生中唯一的梦想就是建立一个大家庭。他解释说，他与四个不同的女人生了四个孩子，但每次当局都把孩子带走了，他再也没见过他们。他轻蔑地谈论儿童保护服务机构和整个政府，解释说他曾经在军队担任医务人员，直到他们开始在未经他同意的情况下给他服用致幻药物。加里告诉约瑟芬娜：“我因为医疗问题去看医生，等他们治疗结束时，我已经彻底疯了。”他说他被军队开除了，此后一直进出精神卫生机构。
ever since. Most recently, Gary had signed up for a matchmaking service which paired American men with women from the Philippines. He'd been matched with a woman named Betty who flew over to the United States to marry him. But Betty wasn't the subservient wife that Gary had dreamed of. She got pregnant and ran out on Gary before their baby was born. She now refused to let Gary see his son while suing him for child support.
最近，加里报名参加了一个婚介服务，将美国男性与菲律宾女性进行配对。他与一名叫贝蒂（Betty）的女子配对，她飞到美国嫁给了他。但贝蒂并不是加里梦想中那种顺从的妻子。她在孩子出生前就怀孕并抛弃了加里。她现在拒绝让加里见他们的儿子，并起诉他索要子女抚养费。
This time, Gary had a plan to make sure that didn't happen again. He told Josephina he intended to hold up to ten women in his basement and impregnate each one. He said he preferred black women, and ideally ones he didn't consider smart. Once the babies were born, Gary said they would all raise them together under the one roof, where no one could interfere, like one big happy family. Josefina listened intently. It occurred to her that not only was Gary deeply unwell, he was also incredibly lonely. She figured her best chance of survival was to play along by lending a sympathetic ear and agreeing with what Gary had to say. After
这一次，加里有一个计划，确保这种情况不会再发生。他告诉约瑟芬娜，他打算在地下室关押多达十名女性，并让她们每个人都怀孕。他说他更喜欢黑人女性，最好是他认为不太聪明的。加里说，一旦孩子出生，他们就会在一个屋檐下一起抚养他们，没有人能干涉，就像一个幸福的大家庭。约瑟芬娜仔细听着。她意识到加里不仅病得很重，而且非常孤独。她认为她生存的最佳机会就是顺从他，做一个善解人意的倾听者，并赞同加里所说的话。在
he was done digging, he left Josefina alone in the basement, chained up but free of the handcuffs. She fell to her knees as the gravity of what he'd told her sank in. Josefina, who was half Puerto Rican and half Mexican, had grown up in a loving foster home after she and her siblings were abandoned by their parents. She adored her foster mother and had enjoyed a comfortable upbringing, going to a good school and on to college. It was only when she'd discovered drugs that things in her life spiralled out of control. Before her chance encounter with Gary, she'd been determined to start the upcoming year with a clean slate. Now realising that Gary had no intention of releasing her anytime soon, Josefina began to panic.
他挖完后，把约瑟芬娜独自留在地下室，虽然锁着链子，但解开了手铐。当他告诉她的事情的严重性沉重地压在她心头时，她跪倒在地。约瑟芬娜是波多黎各和墨西哥混血，在父母抛弃她和兄弟姐妹后，她在充满爱的寄养家庭中长大。她非常爱她的养母，并享受着舒适的成长环境，上了好学校并读了大学。直到她接触毒品，生活才失控。在与加里偶然相遇之前，她决心以全新的面貌迎接新的一年。现在意识到加里根本没有打算放她走，约瑟芬娜开始恐慌。
Thinking of her foster mother and children, she prayed to God that she'd find the strength to get herself out of this situation. Josefina knew that no one would realise she was missing or be out looking for her. At that moment, she made up her mind that she wasn't done living and she was going to get out of that basement no matter what. When Josefina awoke the next day, she was alone in the basement, freezing and with no concept of time. She had an eat in two days and her body and mind were weakening. Then she felt vibrations overhead as the engine of Gary's car began revving in the garage and drove away.
想到她的养母和孩子，她祈求上帝赐予她力量，让她摆脱这种困境。约瑟芬娜知道没有人会意识到她失踪或出来寻找她。那一刻，她下定决心，她还没有活够，无论如何她都要逃出那个地下室。第二天约瑟芬娜醒来时，她独自在地下室，冻得发抖，对时间毫无概念。她已经两天没吃东西了，身体和精神都在衰弱。然后她感觉到头顶有震动，加里车库里的汽车引擎开始轰鸣，然后开走了。
Realising this meant she was alone in the house, Josefina wasted no time. Frantically using all of her remaining strength, she began picking at the superglue on the screw of the right muffler clamp. After about 30 minutes, the screw came loose. Josefina freed her right ankle from the shackles and ran as far as the chain would allow. It was just long enough for her to reach the one small window in the basement. It was only about one and a half feet wide, but Josefina was sure she'd be able to crawl through. She pushed the metal flap on the window and was relieved to feel it open easily, revealing the trash-covered backyard. The welcome sight of daylight flooded into the basement as Josephina
意识到这意味着她独自在家，约瑟芬娜没有浪费时间。她疯狂地用尽最后的力量，开始抠右侧消音器夹螺丝上的强力胶。大约 30 分钟后，螺丝松动了。约瑟芬娜从镣铐中解放了右脚踝，并尽可能地跑向链条允许的范围。链条刚好够长，让她能够够到地下室里唯一的小窗户。窗户只有大约一英尺半宽，但约瑟芬娜确信她能爬过去。她推开窗户上的金属盖，松了一口气，发现它很容易打开，露出了堆满垃圾的后院。当约瑟芬娜试图把自己拉上去时，
tried to hoist herself up, but try as she might, she couldn't fit her body more than a few inches into the window. Still chained to the pipe by one ankle, this left her with very little wiggle room. Josephina could hear voices nearby and started screaming for help at the top of her lungs. The neighbourhood had a large Hispanic population so she screamed in a blend of English and Spanish, explaining that a man had her chained up and was raping her. She begged someone to call the police, saying this man was going to kill her. Josefina could hear every word of what the people nearby were saying, so she couldn't understand why they weren't responding to her desperate pleas for help. She managed to grab hold of a stick and started whacking the neighbouring fence. She did this for almost 20 minutes until finally
欢迎的日光涌入地下室，但无论她怎么努力，她的身体都无法挤进窗户超过几英寸。由于一只脚踝仍被链条锁在管子上，这让她几乎没有活动空间。约瑟芬娜能听到附近有声音，于是开始竭尽全力大声呼救。这个社区有大量的西班牙裔人口，所以她用英语和西班牙语混合着大喊，解释说一个男人把她锁起来并强奸了她。她恳求有人报警，说这个男人要杀了她。约瑟芬娜能听到附近人们说的每一个字，所以她无法理解为什么他们对她绝望的求救没有反应。她设法抓住一根棍子，开始猛击邻居的围栏。她这样做了近 20 分钟，直到最后
somebody heard her. But it wasn't the saviour she was hoping for. It was Gary. Gary was back inside the basement. He grabbed the chain, dragging Josephina away from the window in a way that made her feel like a fish on a line. She used all her strength to maintain her position halfway out of the window, still screaming at the top of her lungs. She managed to jam her free foot against the window frame which effectively secured her in place. Gary let go of the chain and a minute later he appeared in the backyard. He stood over Josefina and tried to push her back into the basement from the outside. She continued fighting against him, all the while yelling at him to get off and begging for someone to call the police. After a few minutes, Gary gave up and went back into the
有人听到了她的声音。但那不是她所希望的救星。是加里。加里回到了地下室。他抓住链条，把约瑟芬娜从窗户边拖走，让她感觉自己像一条鱼钩上的鱼。她用尽全力保持自己半个身子在窗外的姿势，同时继续竭尽全力尖叫。她设法把自由的那只脚卡在窗框上，这有效地把她固定在了原地。加里松开了链条，一分钟后他出现在后院。他站在约瑟芬娜上方，试图从外面把她推回地下室。她继续与他搏斗，同时大喊让他滚开，并恳求有人报警。几分钟后，加里放弃了，回到了
basement. This time, he yanked on Josephina's chain so violently that she was sure her leg would break. The pain was so intense that she relented, letting her body flop as Gary pulled her all the way back inside. Seemingly exhilarated by this victory, he said he'd have to do a better job of securing her shackles this time. As he got to work re-gluing the clamps, he assured Josefina that nobody was going to come to her aid. The neighbourhood was filled with drug dealers, whom he paid to leave him alone. For her attempt to escape, Gary beat Josefina and handcuffed her arms behind her back, leaving her on the hard, cold basement floor. He then bolted the metal flap on the window to the wall and packed the outside with sandbags, sealing off her last possible connection with the outside world.
地下室。这一次，他猛地拉动约瑟芬娜的链条，力道之大让她确信自己的腿会断掉。疼痛如此剧烈，以至于她屈服了，任由身体瘫软，被加里一路拖回了屋里。加里似乎对这次胜利感到兴奋，他说这次他得把她的镣铐锁得更牢固些。当他重新给夹子涂胶水时，他向约瑟芬娜保证，没有人会来救她。这个社区到处都是毒贩，他付钱让他们别管他的闲事。因为她试图逃跑，加里殴打约瑟芬娜，并将她的双臂铐在背后，把她扔在坚硬冰冷的地下室地板上。然后，他用螺栓把窗户上的金属盖固定在墙上，并在外面堆满了沙袋，封死了她与外界最后可能的联系。
The next day, Gary returned to the basement to give Josephina some bread and water and continue digging out the hole in the ground. He raped her again before ordering her back inside the hole. This time it was big enough to fit the air mattress inside and Josefina was able to sit up relatively comfortably compared to the squashed, fetal position she'd been in previously. She heard Gary leave the house, but instead of being relieved that he was gone, she was filled with fear. Gary was the only one who knew she was down there. It occurred to her that if anything happened to him while he was out, she'd be left there to rot. A few hours later, Gary returned, but this time, he wasn't alone. Josephina could hear two sets of
第二天，加里回到地下室给约瑟芬娜一些面包和水，并继续挖掘地上的洞。他又强奸了她，然后命令她回到洞里。这次洞足够大，可以把充气床垫放进去，与之前蜷缩的胎儿姿势相比，约瑟芬娜可以相对舒适地坐起来。她听到加里离开了房子，但她并没有因为他走了而感到宽慰，反而充满了恐惧。加里是唯一知道她在下面的人。她想到如果他在外面出了什么事，她就会被留在那里腐烂。几个小时后，加里回来了，但这次他不是一个人。约瑟芬娜能听到两组
footsteps along with a woman crying. Gary was trying to comfort the woman, saying, Come on Sandy, you know I'm not going to hurt you, right? Why are you crying? You know me. Stop crying. Why are you crying? You know me. Stop crying." Suddenly, light flooded into the hole as Gary removed the plywood board and yanked Josephine up by the arm. A young black woman who looked to be about the same age as herself stood there, naked with her hands cuffed behind her back and in an obvious state of distress. with her hands cuffed behind her back and in an obvious state of distress. Gary introduced the two women as though there was nothing unusual about the circumstances in which they were meeting. He then got to work supergluing another muffler clamp shackle to the ankles of his new victim before padlocking her chains to the sewer pipe. Once he was finished, he ordered both women into
脚步声，还有一个女人的哭声。加里试图安慰那个女人，说：“来吧，桑迪（Sandy），你知道我不会伤害你的，对吧？你为什么哭？你认识我。别哭了。你为什么哭？你认识我。别哭了。”突然，随着加里移开胶合板并抓住约瑟芬娜的手臂把她拉起来，光线涌入洞中。一个看起来和她年纪相仿的年轻黑人女性站在那里，赤身裸体，双手被铐在背后，显然处于极度痛苦的状态。加里介绍这两个女人时，就好像他们见面的环境没什么不寻常一样。然后，他开始用强力胶把另一个消音器夹镣铐固定在他新受害者的脚踝上，并用挂锁把她的链条锁在下水道管上。完成后，他命令两个女人进入
the hole and sealed them inside. Alone with Gary's new captive, Josephina did her best to calm the woman down. She explained that her name was Sandra Lindsay and she was 25 years old. She had known Gary, whose last name was Hyde Nick, for about four years. The two had met through the Erwin Institute, a facility in West Philadelphia that provides support and services to individuals with a range of intellectual and physical disabilities. Sandra was intellectually disabled herself, and although she lived relatively independently, her mental capabilities were more aligned with a 15-year-old. Gary Heidenich was a qualified nurse who had previously worked at the Elwynn Institute, and the two became friends.
洞里，并将她们封在里面。与加里的新俘虏单独在一起，约瑟芬娜尽力让那个女人平静下来。她解释说她的名字叫桑德拉·林赛（Sandra Lindsay），今年 25 岁。她认识加里，他的姓是海德尼克（Heidenich），已经大约四年了。两人是在埃尔温研究所（Elwynn Institute）认识的，这是费城西部的一家机构，为患有各种智力和身体残疾的个人提供支持和服务。桑德拉本人有智力障碍，虽然她生活相对独立，但她的心理能力更接近 15 岁。加里·海德尼克是一名合格的护士，曾在那家研究所工作，两人因此成为了朋友。
Sandra explained to Josefina that Gary had always been good to her, sometimes taking her out to amusement parks, fast food restaurants, or to his place. He was also the self-ordained minister of his own church, which catered specifically to people with intellectual and physical disabilities. Known as the United Church of the Ministers of God, Gary held weekly sermons at his home on Marshall Street where he taught hymns and read Bible passages to the small congregation. Sandra was one of the ten or so followers who attended often. One of the things she liked most about it was that Gary never asked his congregants for money. Earlier that day of Saturday November 29, Sandra had been experiencing menstrual cramps and had
桑德拉向约瑟芬娜解释说，加里一直对她很好，有时带她去游乐园、快餐店或他家。他还是他自己教会的自封牧师，该教会专门为智力和身体残疾人士服务。加里在马歇尔街的家中每周举行布道，被称为“上帝牧师联合教会”（United Church of the Ministers of God），在那里他教唱赞美诗并向一小群会众朗读圣经段落。桑德拉是经常参加的十名左右追随者之一。她最喜欢的一点是，加里从不向他的会众要钱。11 月 29 日星期六那天早些时候，桑德拉一直有痛经，
gone out to buy some painkillers when Gary drove by and offered her a lift. They went out to eat like usual and then back to Gary's house to have sex. Afterwards, he started strangling her and dragged her downstairs. I don't understand it, Sandra cried. Gary's my friend. Why is he doing this? It was clear to Josefina that Sandra didn't fully grasp what was going on. She asked Sandra if she'd ever had sex with Gary before. Sandra responded that she'd had sex with both Gary and a friend of his named Tony Brown. She'd once gotten pregnant by Gary and had an abortion, which made Gary angry. an abortion which made Gary angry. Sandra explained,
出门去买止痛药时，加里开车经过并提出载她一程。他们像往常一样出去吃饭，然后回到加里的家发生性关系。事后，他开始掐她的脖子，并把她拖下楼。桑德拉哭着说：“我不明白。加里是我的朋友。他为什么要这样做？”约瑟芬娜很清楚，桑德拉并没有完全理解发生了什么。她问桑德拉以前是否和加里发生过性关系。桑德拉回答说，她曾与加里以及他的一个名叫托尼·布朗（Tony Brown）的朋友发生过性关系。她曾经怀过加里的孩子并堕胎了，这让加里很生气。桑德拉解释说，
Now he says I'm going to have his baby whether I want to or not. A few hours later Gary returned to the basement. He laid Josefina and Sandra side by side and raped them both. It struck Josefina that he didn't seem to get any particular pleasure from this act. His moves seemed mechanical, reinforcing to her that he was serious about his twisted reproductive mission. Afterwards, he gave the women a shirt each to wear and a portable toilet to use in place of the bucket they'd been using so far. Gary then got back to work digging the hole deeper and wider. When they were left alone, Josephina and Sandra speculated between themselves about what his intentions could be. Was he making space for more captives, or did he intend on burying their bodies in there? Josefina focused on trying to figure out who exactly Gary Heidenich
“现在他说不管我愿不愿意，我都要生下他的孩子。”几个小时后，加里回到地下室。他让约瑟芬娜和桑德拉并排躺下，强奸了她们两人。约瑟芬娜感到震惊的是，他似乎并没有从这种行为中获得任何特别的快感。他的动作看起来很机械，这向她证实了他对扭曲的生殖使命是认真的。事后，他给了每个女人一件衬衫穿，并给了一个便携式马桶，代替她们迄今为止一直使用的水桶。然后，加里又开始把洞挖得更深、更宽。当她们被单独留下时，约瑟芬娜和桑德拉私下猜测他的意图可能是什么。他是在为更多的俘虏腾出空间，还是打算把她们的尸体埋在那里？约瑟芬娜专注于试图弄清楚加里·海德尼克到底
was and what made him tick. Through Sandra, she learned that for the most part, Gary was a kind man, but he didn't like to be told no. He was highly intelligent with a nursing degree, yet received a full disability pension from the government. He'd taught himself how to work the stock market, turning $1500 into a portfolio of over over 500,000 within a decade. He also had schizophrenia and had tried to take his own life on more than one occasion. He was supposed to take a daily dose of a medication called Thorazine, but he didn't always do so and instead sometimes hoarded it up for an overdose. it up for an overdose. The thought of this terrified Josefina. Already feeling like they were living in a permanent grave, she was just as scared of something happening to Gary as she was of something happening to herself. A few days after Sandra's abduction, the women heard someone knocking at the front door. It was Sandra's sister wanting to know if Sandra was there.
是谁，以及是什么让他变得如此。通过桑德拉，她了解到在大多数情况下，加里是一个善良的人，但他不喜欢被拒绝。他非常聪明，拥有护理学位，却从政府领取全额残疾抚养金。他自学了如何操作股票市场，在十年内将 1500 美元变成了超过 50 万美元的投资组合。他还患有精神分裂症，并曾不止一次试图自杀。他本应每天服用一种叫托拉嗪（Thorazine）的药物，但他并不总是这样做，有时反而把药囤积起来准备过量服用。这个想法让约瑟芬娜感到恐惧。她们已经感觉自己生活在一个永久的坟墓里，她对加里出事和对自己出事一样感到害怕。桑德拉被绑架几天后，女人们听到有人在敲前门。是桑德拉的姐姐想知道桑德拉是否在那里。
Shortly after, Gary came downstairs wearing a pair of rubber gloves and holding a pen and paper. He handed these to Sandra and ordered that she write the following message. Dear Mum, do not worry. Will call. Love, Sandy. In her childlike handwriting, Sandra did as she was told. She then wrote her mother's address on an envelope and sealed the letter inside. After this, Gary locked Sandra and Josephina in the hole and left the house, saying he was going to New York to send the letter so that Sandra's family wouldn't come looking for her at his place again. As each hour ticked by, Josefina was gripped by panic at the thought that Gary wasn't coming back.
不久之后，加里戴着橡胶手套，拿着纸和笔下楼。他把这些交给桑德拉，命令她写下以下信息：“亲爱的妈妈，别担心。会打电话。爱你的，桑迪。”桑德拉用她那孩子气的笔迹照做了。然后，她在信封上写下她母亲的地址，并将信封好。此后，加里把桑德拉和约瑟芬娜锁在洞里，离开了房子，说他要去纽约寄这封信，这样桑德拉的家人就不会再来他家找她了。随着时间的流逝，约瑟芬娜因为加里可能不会回来而陷入恐慌。
Over twenty-four hours passed before Josephina felt the vibrations of Gary's car pulling into the garage. She was relieved by the sound and told him as much. Little did she know this was a huge mistake. Gary froze. How did you hear my car? he asked. Only then did it occur to Josefina that the blaring radio had been to prevent her and Sandra from hearing his movements as much as it had been to prevent outsiders from hearing their screams. Silently, Gary went back upstairs. He returned to the basement shortly after with a screwdriver. He pushed Sandra and then Josefina onto the ground.
二十四个多小时过去了，约瑟芬娜才感觉到加里的车开进车库的震动。她听到声音感到如释重负，并告诉了他。她不知道这是一个巨大的错误。加里僵住了。“你是怎么听到我的车的？”他问。直到那时，约瑟芬娜才意识到，震耳欲聋的收音机不仅是为了防止外人听到她们的尖叫，也是为了防止她和桑德拉听到他的动静。加里默默地回到楼上。不久后，他带着一把螺丝刀回到地下室。他把桑德拉和约瑟芬娜推倒在地。
Don't scream, he warned as he inserted the screwdriver into their ears. into their ears. I know how far I can go without making you deaf." With this, a routine was established. Every morning, Gary came down with some bread and water. He'd then rape Josephina and Sandra before continuing work on the hole. If either woman ever put up a fight or screamed, Gary beat them, often with the handle of his shovel, so they quickly learned to comply. Josefina decided that her best chance of survival was to keep quiet and submit to Gary's demands, no matter what. Whenever Gary left the house, he sealed Josefina and Sandra into the hole. He soon brought down a battery-powered television which he let the women take into the hole with them.
“别尖叫，”他警告说，同时把螺丝刀插进她们的耳朵里。“我知道我能走多远而不让你们变聋。”就这样，一种常规建立起来了。每天早上，加里都会带着一些面包和水下来。然后他会强奸约瑟芬娜和桑德拉，之后继续挖掘洞穴。如果任何一个女人反抗或尖叫，加里就会殴打她们，通常是用铲柄，所以她们很快学会了顺从。约瑟芬娜决定，她生存的最佳机会就是保持安静并服从加里的要求，无论发生什么。每当加里离开房子时，他都会把约瑟芬娜和桑德拉封在洞里。他很快拿下来一台电池供电的电视机，让女人们带进洞里看。
The pair discovered that leaving the TV on too long deprived them of precious oxygen, so they had to ration their viewing time to no more than two hours per day. All the while, the radio blared in the background for hours on end, playing a rotation of the same ten or so songs which drove the women mad. Boredom and hunger became a constant. Over time, Gary started bringing down tea bags and sugar along with an old coffee pot the women could use to boil water. They tried to ration their tea bags but loaded each drink with as much sugar as they could handle, desperate for the calories.
两人发现电视开得太久会消耗她们宝贵的氧气，所以她们不得不将观看时间限制在每天不超过两个小时。与此同时，收音机在背景中连续播放了几个小时，循环播放着同样的十首左右的歌曲，这让女人们快要疯了。无聊和饥饿成了常态。随着时间的推移，加里开始带下茶包和糖，以及一个旧咖啡壶，女人们可以用它烧水。她们试图节省茶包，但在每杯饮料里都加了尽可能多的糖，渴望获得热量。
Gary gave the women sanitary products but at no point were they allowed to bathe. Their only method of cleaning themselves was the occasional baby wipe Gary gave them. By Monday December 22, 1986, almost a month had passed since Josefina Rivera and Sandra Lindsay had been held captive at Gary Heidenich's home on North Marshall Street. That night, the two women were lying on the air mattress when the basement door opened suddenly. In came Gary with a young black woman naked in handcuffs. He introduced the woman as Lisa. Chatting jovially as Lisa sobbed, he got to work fitting her with
加里给了女人们卫生用品，但她们在任何时候都不被允许洗澡。她们唯一的清洁方法是加里偶尔给她们的婴儿湿巾。到 1986 年 12 月 22 日星期一，约瑟芬娜·里维拉和桑德拉·林赛被关押在加里·海德尼克位于北马歇尔街的家中已经快一个月了。那天晚上，两个女人正躺在充气床垫上，地下室的门突然开了。加里带着一个赤身裸体、戴着手铐的年轻黑人女性走了进来。他介绍那个女人叫丽莎（Lisa）。在丽莎啜泣时，他愉快地聊天，开始着手给她装上
his trademark muffler clamp shackles and chain. Like with the others, Gary was meticulous about the way he fitted Lisa's restraints. He counted the number of chain links between her ankles to ensure he could still rape her with ease. He also made sure to chain each woman several feet apart so there was enough space for him to rape them one at a time. With Lisa secured to the chain, he then forced her into the hole, sealing her inside before going back upstairs. Josephina and Sandra immediately raced over and started talking into the hole, reassuring Lisa that everything would be okay. They told her to do as Gary said and there wouldn't be any problems. He came back down shortly after, bringing bread and water for the women with him.
他标志性的消音器夹镣铐和链条。和其他人一样，加里对丽莎的束缚方式非常讲究。他数了数她脚踝之间的链环数量，以确保他仍然可以轻松地强奸她。他还确保把每个女人锁在相隔几英尺的地方，这样就有足够的空间让他一次强奸一个。丽莎被锁在链条上后，他强迫她进入洞里，将她封在里面，然后回到楼上。约瑟芬娜和桑德拉立刻冲过去，开始对着洞口说话，安慰丽莎一切都会好起来的。她们告诉她照加里说的做，就不会有任何问题。他不久后回来，带着给女人们的面包和水。
He let Lisa out of the hole and they all ate their meals before Gary laid them down and raped them individually. He then handed Lisa a shirt before disappearing back upstairs. Josephina and Sandra learned that Gary's latest victim was 19-year-old Lisa Thomas, a single mother who lived with her own mother and young son approximately two miles away. Lisa had been walking to retrieve a pair of gloves she'd left at a friend's place when Gary pulled over in his Cadillac, mistaking her for a sex worker. Although Lisa was insulted by this, she couldn't help but be impressed by his expensive car. Gary apologised for the misunderstanding and offered Lisa a ride to make up for it. Lisa thought that Gary seemed nice and she was elured by the prospect of showing up at her friend's house
他把丽莎从洞里放出来，她们都吃了饭，然后加里让她们躺下，分别强奸了她们。然后他递给丽莎一件衬衫，之后消失在楼上。约瑟芬娜和桑德拉得知，加里的最新受害者是 19 岁的丽莎·托马斯（Lisa Thomas），一位单身母亲，与自己的母亲和年幼的儿子住在约两英里外。丽莎当时正走着去取她落在朋友家的一副手套，这时加里开着他的凯迪拉克靠边停下，误以为她是性工作者。虽然丽莎对此感到被冒犯，但她还是不禁对他的昂贵汽车印象深刻。加里为误会道歉，并提出载丽莎一程以作补偿。丽莎觉得加里看起来很不错，而且她被能出现在朋友家门口的前景所吸引。
in a flashy car, so she accepted. After collecting the gloves from her friend, Lisa accepted Gary's offer to join him for dinner. The pair went to a casual dining restaurant for cheeseburgers and fries. As they ate, Gary invited Lisa to accompany him on a trip to Atlantic City the following day. She found herself somewhat intrigued by him. On the outside, he appeared somewhat scruffy and unkempt, but his expensive car and the way he splashed money around led her to wonder if he was secretly wealthy. Lisa told Gary she had nothing to wear,
开着一辆招摇的车，所以她答应了。从朋友那里拿回手套后，丽莎接受了加里的邀请，和他一起去吃晚饭。两人去了一家休闲餐厅吃芝士汉堡和薯条。吃饭时，加里邀请丽莎第二天陪他去大西洋城旅行。她发现自己对他有点好奇。从外表看，他显得有些邋遢和不修边幅，但他昂贵的车和挥金如土的方式让她怀疑他是否是个隐形富豪。丽莎告诉加里她没有衣服穿，
but that wasn't a problem for Gary. He offered to take her to a nearby department store after dinner where she could have $50 to spend on whatever she wanted. Pleased with how the evening was panning out, Lisa agreed to join Gary at his home on Marshall Street to show off her new outfits and watch a movie. She didn't really want to, but felt she owed it to him after how generous he'd been. It was only when Lisa saw his dirty home in the downtrodden neighbourhood that she realised she'd been wrong about his millionaire status. she realised she'd been wrong about his millionaire status. Keeping her disappointment to herself, they sat down to watch a movie together. Lisa started drinking a wine cooler, but she'd also taken an allergy pill over dinner and the combination of the two made her increasingly
但这对于加里来说不是问题。他提议晚饭后带她去附近的百货商店，让她花50美元买任何她想要的东西。丽莎对这个晚上的进展感到满意，同意去加里位于马歇尔街的家中展示她的新衣服并看电影。她其实并不想去，但觉得在他表现得如此慷慨之后，她欠他一个人情。直到丽莎看到他那位于贫民窟的肮脏住所时，她才意识到自己对他百万富翁身份的判断是错误的。她意识到自己对他百万富翁身份的判断是错误的。她把失望藏在心里，两人坐下来一起看电影。丽莎开始喝一种果味酒，但她在晚饭时还吃了一片过敏药，两者的结合让她越来越
drowsy. Before she knew it, she'd nodded off completely. When she woke up, the realisation dawned on her. She was in Gary's bed, completely naked. Lisa consented to having sex with Gary, and when she asked for a ride home afterwards, he launched an attack. He launched an attack. Lisa Thomas' story was becoming all too familiar to Josephina Rivera. Gary had established a clear MO and he showed no signs of stopping anytime soon. But with three women now in the basement, there wasn't enough room for all of them in the hole. Josefina used this to her advantage. She'd been carefully observing Gary's behaviour for weeks and had learned that above all else, what he wanted was praise and adoration. He wanted to feel like the women wanted to be there with him, not that they had to. With this in mind,
昏昏欲睡。还没等她反应过来，她就完全睡着了。当她醒来时，她意识到发生了什么。她躺在加里的床上，赤身裸体。丽莎同意与加里发生性关系，当她事后要求搭车回家时，他发动了攻击。他发动了攻击。丽莎·托马斯的遭遇对约瑟芬娜·里维拉来说已经太熟悉了。加里已经形成了明确的作案手法，而且他没有任何停止的迹象。但现在地下室里有三个女人，地洞里已经容不下她们所有人了。约瑟芬娜利用了这一点。她几周来一直在仔细观察加里的行为，并了解到最重要的是，他想要的是赞美和崇拜。他想感觉这些女人是自愿和他在一起的，而不是被迫的。考虑到这一点，
Josefina worked on strengthening her relationship with Gary by assuring him that she wasn't going anywhere. This tactic worked, and Gary started leaving Josefina in the basement while Sandra and Lisa were still confined to the hole. Eventually, he started bringing the women upstairs one by one so they could bathe, though their chains were always kept on. During these few minutes alone, Josefina engaged Gary in conversation to learn as much about him as she could. He repeated his plan about bringing several more women to the basement so he could impregnate each one and raise a large group of babies. Gary's parents had divorced when he was three years old, after which his mother went on to
约瑟芬娜努力加强与加里的关系，向他保证她哪儿也不会去。这一策略奏效了，加里开始把约瑟芬娜留在地下室，而桑德拉和丽莎仍被关在地洞里。最终，他开始把女人们一个一个带到楼上洗澡，尽管她们总是戴着锁链。在这几分钟的独处时间里，约瑟芬娜与加里交谈，尽可能多地了解他。他重复了他的计划，即带更多的女人到地下室，这样他就可以让她们每个人怀孕，并抚养一大群孩子。加里的父母在他三岁时离婚了，之后他的母亲又
remarry several more times. Both her second and third husbands were black and she began telling Gary that he was of mixed race, having had multiple affairs while married to his father. Gary said he wanted to create the perfect race with no influence from the outside world. His dream for the future was that white and black people would procreate for hundreds of years until there was only one race. Only then did he believe the world would be at peace. While Josefina could sense that Gary was softening towards her, this did little to change the reality of the situation. In their darkest moments, the three captives discussed the possibility of launching an attack against Gary, but without the keys to their padlocks, they knew it was no use.
再婚了好几次。她的第二任和第三任丈夫都是黑人，她开始告诉加里他是混血儿，并在与他父亲结婚期间多次出轨。加里说他想创造一个完美的种族，不受外界影响。他未来的梦想是白人和黑人繁衍几百年，直到只剩下一个种族。只有那时，他才相信世界会和平。虽然约瑟芬娜能感觉到加里对她态度软化，但这并没有改变现实情况。在最黑暗的时刻，这三名俘虏讨论了对加里发动攻击的可能性，但由于没有挂锁的钥匙，她们知道这毫无用处。
If they managed to kill him or knock him unconscious, they'd still be chained to the pipes and left there to starve. Christmas Day was a particularly bleak time for all three women. As the radio announcers wished everyone a happy holiday, it was a quiet day for Josefina, Sandra and Lisa as they thought about their loved ones celebrating without them. Sandra's letter had seemingly thrown her family off Garry's scent, and while Lisa was sure her mother would be looking for her, they had no way of knowing for sure. Besides, they knew how prevalent crime was in the area. With over 300 homicides a year, the police already had their work cut out for them. Gary tried to lighten the mood with an unexpected
如果她们设法杀了他或让他失去知觉，她们仍然会被锁在管道上，留在那里饿死。圣诞节对这三个女人来说是一个特别凄凉的时刻。当电台播音员祝大家节日快乐时，对约瑟芬娜、桑德拉和丽莎来说，这是一个安静的日子，她们想着亲人们在没有她们的情况下庆祝节日。桑德拉的信似乎让她的家人偏离了加里的踪迹，虽然丽莎确信她的母亲会寻找她，但她们无法确定。此外，她们知道该地区的犯罪率有多高。每年有超过300起凶杀案，警察已经忙得不可开交。加里试图用一个意想不到的
surprise. He came into the basement with a menu for a Chinese restaurant, telling the women they could order one dish each. When their meals came, they savoured every mouth-watering bite, relishing the rare feeling of being properly full. Afterwards, Gary ordered the women to lay down and he took turns raping them, but even this couldn't break their spirits. The next few days went by as per usual. As the new year approached, Josefina was consumed with longing for her children and mother on the outside. She knew she couldn't tolerate her living conditions much longer. Regardless, she was grateful for the company of Sandra and Lisa. Having one another to talk to and share the experience with was the only thing keeping them from falling apart completely.
惊喜来缓和气氛。他带着一家中餐馆的菜单来到地下室，告诉女人们她们每人可以点一道菜。当饭菜送来时，她们细细品味着每一口令人垂涎的食物，享受着那种难得的饱腹感。之后，加里命令女人们躺下，轮流强奸她们，但即使这样也无法摧毁她们的意志。接下来的几天照常度过。随着新年的临近，约瑟芬娜对外面的孩子和母亲的思念之情愈发强烈。她知道自己无法再忍受这种生活条件了。无论如何，她很感激有桑德拉和丽莎的陪伴。有彼此可以交谈和分享经历，是支撑她们不至于彻底崩溃的唯一动力。
share the experience with was the only thing keeping them from falling apart completely. When Gary wasn't around, they passed the hours chatting among themselves about their lives, families, and relationships on the outside. Then came New Year's Eve 1986, and with it, a new arrival. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. I love a good deal as much as the next guy, but I'm not going to jump through hoops just to save a few dollars. It has to be simple. So when Mint Mobile claimed I could get a 3-month wireless plan for $15 a month, I was wary. But it turns out it really is that easy. Switching to Mint Mobile is quick and painless, with a user-friendly website, streamlined
分享经历是支撑她们不至于彻底崩溃的唯一动力。当加里不在的时候，她们花时间聊天，谈论外面的生活、家人和人际关系。接着是1986年的除夕夜，随之而来的是一位新成员。Casefile节目稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。我和其他人一样喜欢划算的交易，但我不会为了省几块钱而大费周折。它必须简单。所以当Mint Mobile声称我可以以每月15美元的价格获得3个月的无线套餐时，我持怀疑态度。但事实证明这真的很简单。切换到Mint Mobile既快速又轻松，拥有用户友好的网站、简化的
purchasing and fast activation. The hardest part? Waiting on hold to break up with your old provider. To get started, go to mintmobile.com slash case file. There, you'll see that right now, all three-month plans are only $15 a month, including the Unlimited plan. All plans come with high speed data and unlimited talk and text delivered on the nation's largest 5G network. You can use your own phone with any Mint Mobile plan and keep your old phone number along
购买流程和快速激活。最难的部分？等待与你旧的运营商解约。要开始，请访问mintmobile.com斜杠case file。在那里，你会看到现在所有的三个月套餐每月仅需15美元，包括无限流量套餐。所有套餐都提供高速数据以及在全国最大的5G网络上提供的无限通话和短信。你可以使用自己的手机搭配任何Mint Mobile套餐，并保留你旧的电话号码以及
with all your existing contacts. Find out how easy it is to switch to Mint Mobile and to get three months of premium wireless service for $15 a month. To get this new customer offer and your new three month premium wireless plan for just $15 a month, go to mintmobile.com slash case file.
你现有的所有联系人。了解切换到Mint Mobile并以每月15美元的价格获得三个月优质无线服务是多么容易。要获得此新客户优惠以及您每月仅需15美元的新三个月优质无线套餐，请访问mintmobile.com斜杠case file。
That's mintmobile.com slash case file. Cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at mintmobile.com slash case file. $45 upfront payment required equivalent to $15 per month. New customers on first 3 month plan only. Speeds slower above 40GB on unlimited plan. Additional taxes, fees and restrictions apply. See Mint Mobile for details. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content.
这就是mintmobile.com斜杠case file。将您的无线账单削减至每月15美元，请访问mintmobile.com斜杠case file。需要预付45美元，相当于每月15美元。仅限首次购买3个月套餐的新客户。无限套餐超过40GB后速度会变慢。适用额外的税费、费用和限制。详情请咨询Mint Mobile。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供优质内容。
Gary Hyde and Ick's three captives heard Deborah Dudley before they laid eyes on her. The 23-year-old sex worker had found herself at Marshall Street the same way as the others, having accepted a ride from Gary. But unlike the rest of them who had entered the basement shaking and crying in fear, Deborah was immediately combative. Naked and handcuffed, Deborah fought against Gary with all her might as he began fitting her ankles with muffler clamps. She screamed in his face,
加里·海德尼克的三名俘虏在看到黛博拉·达德利之前就先听到了她的声音。这位23岁的性工作者和别人一样，在接受了加里的搭车后被带到了马歇尔街。但与其他人颤抖着哭泣着进入地下室不同，黛博拉表现得极具攻击性。赤身裸体并戴着手铐，黛博拉在加里开始给她脚踝装上消音器夹时，用尽全力反抗。她对着他的脸尖叫，
swearing and yelling for him to let her go. The other women looked on in terror. When Deborah saw them there, she began screaming at them too. Once Gary managed to restrain Deborah, he ordered her to get into the hole. She refused, saying there was no way she was going down there. Incensed, Gary picked up his shovel and began beating Deborah with the handle. He shoved her into the hole, covered it with the plywood lid, and placed several bags of dirt on top before disappearing back upstairs in a huff. The other three women began reassuring Deborah that it would all be okay if she just stopped fighting. They told her about Gary's deranged plan to impregnate them all and advised her to just do what he said. But Deborah wasn't hearing it. She constantly
咒骂并大喊让他放她走。其他女人惊恐地看着。当黛博拉看到她们在那里时，她也开始对她们尖叫。加里设法制服黛博拉后，命令她进入地洞。她拒绝了，说她绝不会下去。加里大怒，拿起铲子开始用铲柄殴打黛博拉。他把她推进地洞，盖上胶合板盖子，在上面放了几袋土，然后气冲冲地回到楼上。另外三个女人开始安慰黛博拉，说只要她停止反抗，一切都会好起来的。她们告诉她加里让她们怀孕的疯狂计划，并建议她照他说的做。但黛博拉根本听不进去。她不断地
screamed at the others to let her out, and every time Gary came into the basement from then on in, she howled and fought against him. For Josefina, Deborah's determination was somewhat admirable. It turned out that Deborah had lived a hard life surrounded by crime, drugs and abuse, and she'd had to fight every day to survive. But her refusal to submit to Gary's demands also brought a new level of discord to the situation at Marshall Street. The other women watched on as Gary beat Deborah constantly. He began looking for new objects to discipline her with, remarking that nothing he did seemed to make any difference. Eventually, Gary became so frustrated that he started ordering the others to beat Deborah
对其他人尖叫，让她们放她出去，从那时起，每当加里进入地下室，她就嚎叫并反抗他。对于约瑟芬娜来说，黛博拉的决心在某种程度上令人钦佩。事实证明，黛博拉过着充满犯罪、毒品和虐待的艰苦生活，她必须每天为生存而战。但她拒绝服从加里的要求，也给马歇尔街的情况带来了新的不和。其他女人看着加里不断殴打黛博拉。他开始寻找新的物体来惩罚她，并评论说他所做的一切似乎都没有任何区别。最终，加里变得非常沮丧，开始命令其他人殴打黛博拉
on his behalf. As traumatising as she found it, Josefina didn't dare to refuse. She apologised to Deborah afterwards, pleading with her to stop screaming and to just comply. She explained that Gary was mentally ill and their best chance of survival was to do whatever he said. Deborah refused. She called Josephine a week for going along with things for as long as she had and said it was time for them to come up with a proper plan to overcome Gary. After all, there were four of them and only one of him. Josefina repeatedly explained that without the keys to their padlocks it was no use. But Deborah wasn't having a bar of it. She was convinced that someone would hear them if they screamed loud and long enough. Gary started bringing the other women more substantial foods – oatmeal, rice, shriveled
替他代劳。尽管约瑟芬娜感到非常痛苦，但她不敢拒绝。事后她向黛博拉道歉，恳求她停止尖叫，顺从一点。她解释说加里精神有问题，她们生存的最佳机会就是照他说的做。黛博拉拒绝了。她称约瑟芬娜为懦夫，因为她顺从了这么久，并说现在是她们想出一个合适的计划来战胜加里的时候了。毕竟，她们有四个人，而他只有一个。约瑟芬娜反复解释说，没有挂锁的钥匙，这毫无用处。但黛博拉根本不听。她坚信如果她们尖叫得足够大、足够久，就会有人听到。加里开始给其他女人提供更充足的食物——燕麦片、米饭、干瘪的
hot dog sausages and pop tarts – while continuing to feed Debra nothing but bread and water. Life continued on like this for two more weeks until Sunday, January 18 1987, when there was an unexpected change in routine. By this point, Josephina Rivera had been held at Marshall Street for seven and a half weeks, Sandra Lindsay for seven, Lisa Thomas for almost four, and Deborah Dudley for 18 days. That afternoon, the basement door burst open and in came Gary. With him was 18-year-old Jackie Askins. Jackie was a sex worker who'd been waiting on a corner roughly three and a half miles from Gary's house when Gary pulled up. Jackie had been working alongside another woman and they started arguing over which one of them should get his business. Jackie lied to Gary, warning him that the other woman had a sexually transmitted disease and he should pick her instead.
热狗香肠和果酱馅饼——同时继续只给黛博拉喂面包和水。生活就这样又持续了两周，直到1987年1月18日星期日，例行公事发生了意想不到的变化。此时，约瑟芬娜·里维拉在马歇尔街被关押了七周半，桑德拉·林赛七周，丽莎·托马斯近四周，黛博拉·达德利18天。那天下午，地下室的门被撞开了，加里走了进来。和他在一起的是18岁的杰基·阿斯金斯。杰基是一名性工作者，当时正在距离加里家约3.5英里的街角等候，加里开车停了下来。杰基当时正和另一个女人一起工作，她们开始争论谁该接他的生意。杰基对加里撒了谎，警告他说那个女人有性病，他应该选她。
To Jackie's delight, Gary did just that. While she didn't typically go home with her clients, Gary had a cake on his back seat which he said was for his daughter's birthday and he needed to get it into the fridge. and he needed to get it into the fridge. Gary seemed harmless, so Jackie agreed. She was playing one of the arcade games in his living room when he suddenly grabbed her in a headlock from behind. Jackie put up a fight, but it was no use. Gary managed to handcuff her and to drag her down the steps into the basement. Jackie was visibly terrified. She screamed for Gary to let her go, but this only resulted in a beating. Gary warned Jackie there would be plenty more of that if she didn't obey his commands.
令杰基高兴的是，加里确实照做了。虽然她通常不会和客户回家，但加里的后座上有一个蛋糕，他说那是给他女儿过生日的，他需要把它放进冰箱。他需要把它放进冰箱。加里看起来人畜无害，所以杰基同意了。当她在客厅玩街机游戏时，他突然从背后锁住了她的喉咙。杰基进行了反抗，但无济于事。加里设法给她戴上手铐，把她拖下台阶带进地下室。杰基明显被吓坏了。她尖叫着让加里放她走，但这只换来了一顿毒打。加里警告杰基，如果她不服从他的命令，还会有更多的惩罚。
As soon as Gary left, Josefina went over to Jackie and told her to be quiet. I'm going to get you out of here, she said, but you gotta be patient. By the next evening, Gary's mood was markedly different. It was Josefina's 26th birthday, and he surprised the group with a special treat. Like he'd done at Christmas, he handed the women a menu for a Chinese restaurant and told them to order one dish each. He returned shortly after with the food, a cake, and a present for Josefina, a pair of red, fluffy slippers. He cracked open a bottle of sparkling cider and danced with Josephina to the song Purple Rain by Prince. But it wasn't just the birthday or the introduction of his latest victim
加里一离开，约瑟芬娜就走到杰基身边，告诉她保持安静。“我会救你出去的，”她说，“但你必须有耐心。”到了第二天晚上，加里的心情明显不同了。那是约瑟芬娜的26岁生日，他给这群人带来了一个特别的惊喜。就像圣诞节时那样，他递给女人们一份中餐馆的菜单，告诉她们每人点一道菜。不久后，他带着食物、一个蛋糕和给约瑟芬娜的礼物——一双红色的毛绒拖鞋回来了。他打开一瓶气泡苹果酒，和约瑟芬娜一起随着普林斯的《紫雨》跳舞。但不仅仅是生日或他最新受害者的加入
that gave Gary Heidenich cause to celebrate. He had reason to believe that both Josefina and Sandra were pregnant. For Josefina, the realisation that her period was two months late sparked mixed feelings. On one hand, the possibility that she could be pregnant with Gary Hydenyck's baby sickened her to the core. On the other hand, she wondered whether Gary would treat her better if she was carrying his child. The slippers he gave her seemed like a good sign that her plan to befriend him was working. Josephina reasoned that he wouldn't give a present to somebody he didn't like, and he certainly hadn't given this type of treatment to any of the others.
让加里·海德尼克有理由庆祝。他有理由相信约瑟芬娜和桑德拉都怀孕了。对于约瑟芬娜来说，意识到月经推迟了两个月，心情十分复杂。一方面，她可能怀上加里·海德尼克的孩子的可能性让她感到恶心。另一方面，她想知道如果她怀了他的孩子，加里是否会对她好一点。他送给她的拖鞋似乎是一个好迹象，表明她与他交朋友的计划正在奏效。约瑟芬娜推断，他不会给一个他不喜欢的人送礼物，而且他肯定没有这样对待过其他人。
and he certainly hadn't given this type of treatment to any of the others. On the downside, it was clear that the other women weren't happy about the positive attention she was receiving. The general vibe between the group was beginning to sour. With the number of captives growing, Gary started implementing a kind of hierarchy system. Given that Josefina, Sandra, and Lisa had been there the longest and were the most compliant, they were allowed out of the hole and to sleep on a regular mattress. Deborah's rebellious behaviour earned her a near constant spot in the hole, while Jackie, as the newest captive, was mostly kept with her. Gary began pitting the women against one another by leaving one of them in charge whenever he left them alone. He'd encourage the one in charge to tell on the others if they misbehaved. Those who fell out of line received beatings, extra time in
他肯定没有这样对待过其他人。不利的一面是，很明显其他女人对她受到的优待并不高兴。群体之间的整体氛围开始恶化。随着俘虏人数的增加，加里开始实施一种等级制度。鉴于约瑟芬娜、桑德拉和丽莎待的时间最长且最顺从，她们被允许离开地洞，睡在普通的床垫上。黛博拉的反叛行为使她几乎一直被关在地洞里，而杰基作为最新的俘虏，大部分时间也和她关在一起。加里开始让女人们互相争斗，每当他离开时，就让其中一个人负责。他会鼓励负责人举报其他人的不当行为。那些不听话的人会遭到殴打、额外的时间在
the hole, or worse still, they were subjected to a stretch torture device that Gary introduced in late January. He installed a hook into a ceiling rafter and forced the disobedient woman to stand suspended by a single handcuff, her arms held overhead for hours with her feet barely able to touch the floor. The sexual assaults also remained a daily occurrence. Sometimes Gary raped just one woman, other times he'd go from one to the next, or forced the women to perform sex acts on each other. If they submitted without a fight, he'd reward them with treats, such as cookies. The women were so deprived of food that they found themselves scrambling over one another in the hopes that they'd be the chosen victim for the
地洞里，或者更糟的是，她们会受到加里在1月下旬引入的拉伸酷刑装置的折磨。他在天花板椽子上安装了一个钩子，强迫不听话的女人单手戴着手铐悬空站立，双臂高举数小时，双脚几乎无法触地。性侵犯也依然是每天都会发生的事情。有时加里只强奸一个女人，有时他会从一个轮到下一个，或者强迫女人们互相进行性行为。如果她们不反抗就顺从，他会用饼干之类的零食奖励她们。女人们因为极度缺乏食物，以至于她们发现自己为了能成为当天的受害者而争先恐后。
day. When they were brought upstairs to bathe, each used this time alone with Gary to their perceived advantage. Gary still suspected that Josefina and Sandra were pregnant, but they weren't given pregnancy tests to confirm this. If the two women really were pregnant, Gary wasn't giving them any special treatment such as extra food needed to nourish a baby. While Josefina was gaining a bit of weight despite the restricted diet, the symptoms she'd experienced with her other three pregnancies were notably absent. She suspected that the slight weight gain could be a result of withdrawing from drugs. As for Sandra, she hadn't been feeling well for weeks.
当她们被带到楼上洗澡时，每个人都利用这段与加里的独处时间来为自己谋取所谓的利益。加里仍然怀疑约瑟芬娜和桑德拉怀孕了，但她们没有进行验孕来确认这一点。如果这两个女人真的怀孕了，加里并没有给她们任何特殊的照顾，比如滋养婴儿所需的额外食物。虽然约瑟芬娜尽管饮食受限，体重还是增加了一点，但她在前三次怀孕时经历的症状却明显没有出现。她怀疑体重的轻微增加可能是戒毒的结果。至于桑德拉，她已经好几周感觉不舒服了。
As the days passed, she began eating less and less, which angered Gary as she needed the nutrients for the baby. Thinking Sandra was rebelling by refusing to eat, in early February he put her in the hole, but then caught her trying to push aside the plywood lid. As punishment, Gary handcuffed one of Sandra's arms to the ceiling hook and left her suspended there for days. The other women watched on in horror as Sandra's health deteriorated. She began vomiting and came down with a fever, unable to eat the meager amounts that were given to her. Gary tried to force feed her a piece of bread. When Sandra wouldn't swallow it, Gary beat her across the legs with a stick and ordered that she do as she was told.
随着日子一天天过去，她开始吃得越来越少，这激怒了加里，因为她需要营养来维持胎儿。加里认为桑德拉通过拒绝进食来反抗，于是在2月初把她关进了地洞，但随后发现她试图推开胶合板盖子。作为惩罚，加里把桑德拉的一只手臂铐在天花板的钩子上，让她悬挂在那里好几天。其他女人惊恐地看着桑德拉的健康状况恶化。她开始呕吐并伴有发烧，无法吃下给她的微薄食物。加里试图强行喂她一块面包。当桑德拉不肯吞下时，加里用棍子抽打她的腿，命令她照做。
Sandra began choking and spat the bread out, seemingly too tired to even hold her own body weight. While Gary was convinced that Sandra was faking being sick just to be defiant, the others knew this was no joke. When Gary went back upstairs, they noticed that Sandra's body had completely slumped forward. She appeared to have lost consciousness completely. The women encouraged Sandra to wake up, but Gary heard the commotion and came rushing back into the basement. Finding Sandra's lifeless body hanging there, Gary unlocked the handcuffs. Her body slammed to the floor. Fury in his voice, he added. Now I've lost another baby. Gary hoisted Sandra's lifeless body over his shoulder and carried her upstairs,
桑德拉开始窒息并吐出了面包，似乎太累了，连自己的体重都支撑不住。虽然加里确信桑德拉只是为了反抗而假装生病，但其他人知道这不是开玩笑。当加里回到楼上时，她们注意到桑德拉的身体完全瘫软了下去。她似乎完全失去了知觉。女人们鼓励桑德拉醒来，但加里听到了骚动，冲回了地下室。发现桑德拉毫无生气的身体悬挂在那里，加里解开了手铐。她的身体重重地摔在地板上。他愤怒地补充道：“现在我又失去了一个孩子。”加里把桑德拉毫无生气的身体扛在肩上，带到了楼上，
leaving the other four women in a state of shock. Josefina was particularly shaken. Not only had she and Sandra been in this ordeal together from the start, she'd felt quite protective of Sandra. Josefina couldn't help but feel that she'd failed by not delivering on her promise to get them out of there. The sheer lack of concern from Gary was also cause for alarm. He'd known Sandra for years and she'd considered him a friend, yet he showed nothing but casual indifference to her death. If he could treat Sandra that way, Josephine knew none of them were safe. The remaining four women spent the night mostly in stunned silence, shaken by what they'd witnessed.
留下其他四个女人处于震惊之中。约瑟芬娜尤其感到动摇。她和桑德拉不仅从一开始就一起经历了这场磨难，她还对桑德拉感到相当保护。约瑟芬娜不禁感到自己失败了，因为她没有兑现带她们离开那里的承诺。加里表现出的极度冷漠也令人担忧。他认识桑德拉多年，她一直把他当作朋友，但他对她的死却表现出漫不经心的冷漠。如果他能那样对待桑德拉，约瑟芬娜知道她们中没有一个人是安全的。剩下的四个女人在震惊中度过了大部分夜晚，被她们所目睹的一切吓坏了。
The next morning a foul stench filled the basement. None of the women had ever smelled anything like it and they struggled to breathe in the putrid air. When Gary came downstairs, the smell only got worse. It seemed to have soaked into his hair and skin, and the women were forced to breathe it in every time he raped them. While Sandra's death had temporarily shaken Deborah Dudley into silence, it didn't take long for her to snap out of it. Within three days, Deborah resumed screaming and fighting. Sick of being in the hole, she began bashing against the lid and trying to fight Gary off when he came down to discipline her. Fed up, he stormed downstairs with a key in one hand.
第二天早上，一股恶臭弥漫在地下室。女人们从未闻过这样的味道，她们在腐臭的空气中呼吸困难。当加里下楼时，气味变得更糟了。它似乎已经渗进了他的头发和皮肤里，女人们每次被他强奸时都被迫呼吸这种气味。虽然桑德拉的死暂时让黛博拉·达德利陷入了沉默，但没过多久她就恢复了过来。三天之内，黛博拉又开始尖叫和反抗。厌倦了待在地洞里，她开始撞击盖子，并在加里下来惩罚她时试图反抗。加里忍无可忍，手里拿着一把钥匙冲下楼。
He unlocked Deborah's padlock and dragged her upstairs while the other women looked on in fear. A few minutes later, Gary returned a visibly shaken Debra to the basement, locked her up, and then disappeared again. The others could see that Debra was clearly traumatised by whatever had happened upstairs. They asked her what was wrong, but she was too disturbed to speak. She huddled in the corner, hugging her knees to her chest. The others pressed on before Debra eventually spoke. He showed me Sandra's head, she said. It's sitting in a pot and he's boiling it on the stove. Her ribs are in a roasting pan in the oven and he's got her arms and legs in the freezer. He told me if I don't change my attitude, I'll end up the same way.
他解开了黛博拉的挂锁，把她拖到楼上，而其他女人惊恐地看着。几分钟后，加里把明显受到惊吓的黛博拉带回地下室，锁上她，然后再次消失了。其他人可以看出黛博拉显然被楼上发生的事情吓坏了。她们问她怎么了，但她太不安了，说不出话来。她蜷缩在角落里，双膝抱胸。其他人继续追问，黛博拉终于开口了。“他给我看了桑德拉的头，”她说，“它放在锅里，他在炉子上煮着。她的肋骨在烤箱里的烤盘里，他把她的胳膊和腿放在冰箱里。他告诉我，如果我不改变态度，我也会落得同样的下场。”
Shortly after Sandra Lindsay's death, the other women were watching the television when a dog food commercial came on. As the camera panned over chunks of meat and vegetables, Debra and Jackie made some off-hand comments about how good the dog food looked. Gary was downstairs at the time and their remarks immediately piqued his interest. The next day, he returned with an open can of dog food and a fork and passed it to Deborah and Jackie in the hole. Eat it, he demanded. The women did as they were told, while Josefina and Lisa looked on in disgust. From that point on, canned dog food became part of their usual diet.
桑德拉·林赛死后不久，其他女人们正在看电视，这时播放了一个狗粮广告。当镜头扫过肉块和蔬菜时，黛博拉和杰基随口评论说狗粮看起来很好吃。加里当时在楼下，她们的话立刻引起了他的兴趣。第二天，他带回了一罐打开的狗粮和一把叉子，递给地洞里的黛博拉和杰基。“吃掉它，”他命令道。女人们照做了，而约瑟芬娜和丽莎则厌恶地看着。从那时起，罐装狗粮成了她们日常饮食的一部分。
Meanwhile, the beatings and rapes continued daily. Deborah and Jackie couldn't take any more. Having witnessed what Gary did to Sandra, they knew he had absolutely no regard for whether they lived or died. If they wanted to get out of there alive, it was time to act. One day, when they thought Gary was out of earshot, they told Josefina and Lisa they had a plan. The next time Gary came down, the four of them would launch an attack against him. With four against one and armed with the stick he'd been using to beat them with, the pair were confident they could overpower him. Alternatively, knowing that Josefina often received preferential treatment, they urged her to try and steal a knife next time she was allowed upstairs.
与此同时，殴打和强奸每天都在继续。黛博拉和杰基再也受不了了。目睹了加里对桑德拉所做的一切，她们知道他根本不在乎她们的死活。如果她们想活着离开那里，就必须采取行动。有一天，当她们认为加里不在听力范围内时，她们告诉约瑟芬娜和丽莎她们有一个计划。下次加里下来时，她们四个人就对他发动攻击。四对一，再加上他用来殴打她们的棍子，两人确信她们可以制服他。或者，考虑到约瑟芬娜经常受到优待，她们敦促她下次被允许上楼时试着偷一把刀。
They could wait until Gary was raping one of them and then stab him in the back. Josefina thought it was a terrible idea and told them as much. Without the keys to their padlocks, they'd be doomed. But Debra and Jackie thought it was worth a shot. They argued it was entirely possible that Gary had been keeping the keys in his pockets all along. When Josephina still refused to help, the others accused her of siding with Gary, saying she'd been down there so long that she was starting to like it. As for Debra and Jackie, they were going to do it with or without her help. The next day, Gary brought Josefina upstairs for a bath and outright asked her about their
她们可以等加里强奸其中一个人的时候，从背后捅他一刀。约瑟芬娜认为这是一个糟糕的主意，并告诉了她们。没有挂锁的钥匙，她们就死定了。但黛博拉和杰基认为值得一试。她们争辩说，加里一直把钥匙放在口袋里是完全可能的。当约瑟芬娜仍然拒绝帮忙时，其他人指责她站在加里那边，说她在那里待得太久，开始喜欢上那里了。至于黛博拉和杰基，她们决定无论有没有她的帮助都要去做。第二天，加里带约瑟芬娜上楼洗澡，并直接问她关于她们
scheming. Realising he must have overheard the entire conversation, Josephina replied as casually as she could that there had been some talks between the others, but she'd dismissed their plan. When they went back downstairs, Gary told the others he knew what they were up to. He assured them he didn't carry the keys around with him. One wrong move, and they'd all die down there. Deborah and Jackie were furious with the Josephina, believing she'd ratted them out. But that didn't stop them from trying to get out. One day, Gary pretended to leave in his car just to see what they'd do while he was gone. As soon as they thought
密谋的事情。意识到他一定听到了整个谈话，约瑟芬娜尽可能随意地回答说，其他人之间确实有一些谈话，但她已经驳回了她们的计划。当她们回到楼下时，加里告诉其他人他知道她们在搞什么鬼。他向她们保证他并没有随身携带钥匙。只要有任何轻举妄动，她们都会死在那里。黛博拉和杰基对约瑟芬娜非常愤怒，认为她出卖了她们。但这并没有阻止她们试图逃跑。有一天，加里假装开车离开，只是为了看看她们在他走后会做什么。一旦她们认为
he'd driven away, Deborah and Jackie began screaming and banging on the lid of the hole. Gary burst in and dragged them out. Along with Lisa, he handcuffed each woman to the hook in the ceiling one at a time and covered their mouths with duct tape. hook in the ceiling one at a time and covered their mouths with duct tape. Just like he'd done with Josephina and Sandra earlier, he took a screwdriver and jammed it into their ears until pus came out. Jackie felt her spirits beginning to break completely. She later told Deborah there was no point screaming. There's nobody out there, she said. The only one who can hear you cry is God. By mid-March 1987, Deborah Dudley had been held captive at Marshall Street for two and a half months, but still she refused to comply with Gary Hydenick's demands. It was a constant source of contention between the other women who urged her to stay quiet for her own sake as well as theirs. Jackie did her best to fall into line,
他已经开车走了，黛博拉和杰基就开始尖叫并敲打地洞的盖子。加里冲了进来，把她们拖了出来。他和丽莎一起，一次一个地把每个女人铐在天花板的钩子上，并用胶带封住了她们的嘴。一次一个地把每个女人铐在天花板的钩子上，并用胶带封住了她们的嘴。就像他之前对约瑟芬娜和桑德拉所做的那样，他拿出一把螺丝刀，猛地扎进她们的耳朵里，直到脓液流出来。杰基感到自己的精神开始彻底崩溃。她后来告诉黛博拉，尖叫是没有意义的。“外面没有人，”她说，“唯一能听到你哭泣的是上帝。”到1987年3月中旬，黛博拉·达德利在马歇尔街被囚禁了两个半月，但她仍然拒绝服从加里·海德尼克的要求。这是其他女人之间不断争论的根源，她们敦促她为了自己和她们的利益保持安静。杰基尽力顺从，
but because she was usually kept in the hole with Debra, she was often deemed guilty by association. One day, Gary came up with a new idea to try to get all of the women to behave. He took the lid off the hole, ran a hose into it and filled it with a few inches of water. He then handcuffed Debra and Jackie together and ordered them back into the hole, placing the lid on top. Gary took an extension cord which had been stripped on one end to expose the wires within. He plugged it in and touched the bare wire to the women's chains, sending an electric shock jolting into their bodies. Panicked screams emanated from
但因为她通常和黛博拉一起被关在地洞里，她经常被视为同谋。有一天，加里想出了一个新主意，试图让所有的女人都听话。他拿掉地洞的盖子，把一根软管伸进去，灌了几英寸的水。然后他把黛博拉和杰基铐在一起，命令她们回到地洞里，盖上盖子。加里拿了一根延长线，一端剥开露出里面的电线。他插上电源，将裸露的电线触碰女人们的锁链，一股电流冲击着她们的身体。恐慌的尖叫声从
within the hall. A few seconds later, Gary removed the wire and ordered Josephina to have a turn administering a shock. The very thought sickened her, but she knew that she'd pay the price if she didn't comply. Reluctantly, she did as she was told. With Deborah and Jackie thrashing and crying inside the hole, Gary seemed satisfied. He unplugged the cord, telling them, Now you think about that for a while, before disappearing upstairs. Gary's latest torture device filled the four women with a whole new sense of dread. If his plan really was to impregnate them all, then electrocuting them didn't sound like a smart way to go about it. They worried about what this meant for his state of mind. The other women were also furious at Josephina for obeying his commands and this only added fuel to their belief that she was
地洞里传出。几秒钟后，加里拔掉电线，命令约瑟芬娜轮流施加电击。这个想法让她感到恶心，但她知道如果不服从，她会付出代价。她不情愿地照做了。看着黛博拉和杰基在地洞里挣扎哭泣，加里似乎很满意。他拔掉电源线，告诉她们：“现在你们好好反省一下，”然后消失在楼上。加里最新的酷刑装置让四个女人充满了全新的恐惧感。如果他的计划真的是让她们所有人都怀孕，那么电击她们听起来并不是一个明智的做法。她们担心这对他的精神状态意味着什么。其他女人也对约瑟芬娜服从他的命令感到愤怒，这进一步加剧了她们认为她
siding with him. Two days later, Gary was back in the basement. This time he ordered Deborah, Jackie and Lisa into the water-filled hole. He plugged in the cord and administered a shock before ordering Josefina to do the same. As she hesitantly touched the exposed wires to Debra's chains, the three women inside began screaming. screaming. He's killing me! – Deborah shrieked. Then the basement fell silent. Thinking the cord must have stopped working, Gary raced upstairs to grab another one. But inside the hole, Lisa and Jackie watched on in horror as Deborah's body went limp and collapsed face first into the water. Outside, Josefina heard them announce, Debbie's dead. When Gary returned to the basement ten minutes later, it took him a moment to realise that
站在他那边的想法。两天后，加里回到地下室。这次他命令黛博拉、杰基和丽莎进入装满水的地洞。他插上电源线并进行了电击，然后命令约瑟芬娜也这样做。当她犹豫着将裸露的电线触碰黛博拉的锁链时，里面的三个女人开始尖叫。尖叫。“他在杀我！”黛博拉尖叫道。然后地下室陷入了沉默。加里以为电线一定坏了，冲上楼去拿另一根。但在地洞里，丽莎和杰基惊恐地看着黛博拉的身体瘫软下来，脸朝下倒在水里。外面，约瑟芬娜听到她们宣布：“黛比死了。”当加里十分钟后回到地下室时，他花了一会儿才意识到
the women weren't messing around. He removed the lid from the hole, uncuffed Lisa into Jackie, and dragged Deborah's lifeless body out by the hair. He laid her out on the floor and looked at the others. Aren't you glad it wasn't one of you, he remarked, before adding, thank God, now my troubles are over and my basement can go back to normal.'" As the three surviving women stood around, frozen in shock and fear, he made them each a sandwich. He went upstairs and fetched them each a cigarette and a can of beer. Then he handed Josefina a piece of paper and a pen and told her to write the following
女人们不是在开玩笑。他移开了地洞的盖子，解开了丽莎和杰基的手铐，抓着头发把黛博拉毫无生气的身体拖了出来。他把她平放在地板上，看着其他人。“你们不庆幸死的不是你们中的一个吗？”他评论道，然后补充说：“谢天谢地，现在我的麻烦结束了，我的地下室可以恢复正常了。”当三个幸存的女人站在那里，因震惊和恐惧而僵住时，他给她们每人做了一个三明治。他上楼给她们每人拿了一支香烟和一罐啤酒。然后他递给约瑟芬娜一张纸和一支笔，告诉她写下以下
message. March 18th, 1987. I, Josefina Rivera and Gary Heidnik killed Deborah Dudley by applying electricity to her chain while sitting in a pool of water in a hole in a basement of 3520 Marshall Street. Josephina did as she was told. She put her signature on the bottom and handed it to Jackie and Lisa so they could both sign it as witnesses. Gary held the letter up and said, If you ever go to the cops, I can use this as evidence that you killed Debbie. go to the cops, I can use this as evidence that you killed Debbie." For the first time in almost four months, he then leaned over and unlocked Josefina's chains. Go upstairs and go to bed, he said. In the most extreme of circumstances, it slowly dawned on Josefina that her plan had worked. All those months of complying with Gary's twisted demands and lending him a sympathetic
信息。“1987年3月18日。我，约瑟芬娜·里维拉和加里·海德尼克通过在3520号马歇尔街地下室地洞的水池中对锁链施加电流，杀死了黛博拉·达德利。”约瑟芬娜照做了。她在底部签了名，并把它交给杰基和丽莎，让她们作为证人签名。加里举起信说：“如果你们以后去报警，我可以把这作为你们杀了黛比的证据。”这是近四个月来第一次，他俯身解开了约瑟芬娜的锁链。“上楼去睡觉吧，”他说。在最极端的情况下，约瑟芬娜慢慢意识到她的计划奏效了。那几个月来顺从加里扭曲的要求并借给他一个同情的
ear had finally paid off. He no longer viewed her as a slave, but as a partner. She was allowed to bathe, put on clean clothes, and walk around his house unsupervised and unrestrained. Having succeeded in his plan to get her pregnant, Gary no longer raped her either. But for all these improvements, Josefina was far from free. All of the windows in Gary's home had bars on them, he didn't appear to own a phone, and his front door could only be opened with the sawn off key that he kept safe in his pocket. Josefina also knew that if she made any attempt to escape, Lisa and Jackie's lives would be
耳朵终于得到了回报。他不再把她视为奴隶，而是视为伙伴。她被允许洗澡、穿上干净的衣服，并在他的房子里不受监督和束缚地走动。由于成功实现了让她怀孕的计划，加里也不再强奸她了。但尽管有这些改善，约瑟芬娜远未获得自由。加里家所有的窗户都有栅栏，他似乎没有电话，他的前门只能用他放在口袋里妥善保管的锯断的钥匙打开。约瑟芬娜也知道，如果她试图逃跑，丽莎和杰基的生命将
at immediate risk. If Josefina got out, she had no doubt that Gary would kill the others and destroy evidence of his crimes. For the next couple of days, she tried to go about life as normally as possible, following Gary around and doing whatever he asked. Despite the trauma of the past few months being exacerbated by Debra's death, Josephina made a conscious effort not to display any emotion or act shocked by anything Gary did or said. The only time her tough exterior almost cracked was when Gary brought her into the kitchen and showed her Sandra Lindsay's charred
处于直接危险之中。如果约瑟芬娜逃出去，她毫不怀疑加里会杀死其他人并销毁他犯罪的证据。接下来的几天里，她尽量让生活尽可能正常，跟着加里，做他要求的任何事情。尽管黛比的死加剧了过去几个月的创伤，但约瑟芬娜还是有意识地努力不表现出任何情绪，也不对加里所做或所说的一切表现出震惊。她坚强的外表唯一一次差点崩溃，是加里把她带进厨房，给她看了桑德拉·林赛烧焦的
and rotting remains, which he'd attempted to dispose of just as Deborah had described. But there was something the others didn't know. Gary revealed to Josefina that he'd tried to feed Sandra's remains to the neighbourhood dogs, but they'd left the obviously human bones scattered around his backyard. He said that Sandra's family suspected he had something to do with her disappearance so he had to be incredibly careful not to attract any attention to himself. It was only when Deborah commented about how good the dog food commercial looked that Gary got an idea. He said he started mincing up Sandra's remains and mixing them in with the canned dog food, which he then fed to the women downstairs.
和腐烂的遗骸，他试图像黛博拉描述的那样处理掉它们。但还有一些其他人不知道的事情。加里向约瑟芬娜透露，他曾试图把桑德拉的遗骸喂给附近的狗，但它们把明显是人类的骨头散落在他的后院。他说桑德拉的家人怀疑她的失踪与他有关，所以他必须非常小心，不能引起任何人的注意。直到黛博拉评论说狗粮广告看起来很好吃时，加里才有了主意。他说他开始把桑德拉的遗骸剁碎，混进罐装狗粮里，然后喂给楼下的女人们吃。
Josefina did her best to remain expressionless, while inside she was reeling from the extreme horror of it all. Gary went on to explain that they wouldn't have to be so careful with Debra. No one knew he was linked to her in any way, so all they had to do was find a good spot to dispose of her body. If the cops ever found her, there would be nothing to tie her back to Marshall Street. Gary took Josefina for a drive to the neighbouring state of New Jersey on the lookout for the perfect spot to dump Deborah's body. Along the way, they stopped in at a McDonald's restaurant so Gary could get something to eat. Josephina didn't look anyone in the eye in case Gary misinterpreted her intentions. They drove along Route 676 in the densely forested pine barrens of Wharton State Forest,
约瑟芬娜尽力保持面无表情，而内心却因这一切的极端恐怖而翻江倒海。加里继续解释说，她们不必对黛博拉如此小心。没有人知道他与她有任何联系，所以她们所要做的就是找个好地方处理掉她的尸体。如果警察真的发现了她，也不会有任何东西能把她和马歇尔街联系起来。加里带着约瑟芬娜开车前往邻近的新泽西州，寻找丢弃黛博拉尸体的完美地点。一路上，他们在麦当劳餐厅停下来，让加里买点吃的。约瑟芬娜没有看任何人的眼睛，以免加里误解她的意图。他们沿着676号公路行驶，穿过沃顿州立森林茂密的松林荒原，
about 40 miles east of North Philadelphia. Eventually, Gary pulled down a discreet dirt track that led about a hundred yards into the woods and determined, this will do. Later that night, under the cover of darkness, Gary retrieved Deborah's body from a freezer in the basement. He'd been keeping her there, folded over into a clear garbage bag. Ordering Josefina to follow him, he carried the bag to his garage and dumped the body into the trunk of his Cadillac. The pair then made their way back to the Pine Barrens and to the location that Gary had scouted earlier. Josephina didn't dare move as Gary removed the keys from the engine and carried Deborah's
位于北费城以东约40英里处。最终，加里把车开进了一条隐蔽的土路，这条路通向树林深处约一百码的地方，他认定这里正合适。那天深夜，在夜色的掩护下，加里从地下室的冰柜里取出了黛博拉的尸体。他一直把她折叠着塞进一个透明的垃圾袋里，藏在那里。他命令约瑟芬娜跟着他，随后将袋子搬到车库，把尸体扔进了他凯迪拉克轿车的后备箱。两人随后回到松林荒原，来到加里早先踩好点的地方。当加里拔掉引擎钥匙，抱着黛博拉的尸体走进黑暗的树林时，约瑟芬娜一动也不敢动。
frozen body into the dark woods. As she sat there in the car alone, she thought about running off. Her heart pounded as she wondered what would happen if Gary caught her. It then occurred to her that he might have brought her along just so he could kill her and dump her body there too. By the time Gary returned to the car, Josefina was almost relieved. She spent the rest of the drive tense and traumatised by what they'd just done. Meanwhile, Gary seemed completely unfazed. Again, he stopped at McDonald's for a burger and fries, checking his stocks in a newspaper and remarking on their poor performance, as though burying a body in the woods was a common occurrence.
当她独自坐在车里时，她想到了逃跑。她的心怦怦直跳，担心如果被加里抓住会发生什么。她突然想到，他带她来可能只是为了杀了她，然后把她的尸体也扔在那里。当加里回到车上时，约瑟芬娜几乎感到如释重负。在剩下的车程中，她一直处于紧张和创伤之中，因为他们刚刚所做的一切。与此同时，加里似乎完全不受影响。他再次在麦当劳停下来买汉堡和薯条，查看报纸上的股票，并评论它们表现不佳，就好像在树林里埋尸体是一件平常事一样。
a body in the woods was a common occurrence. For the first time, it occurred to Josefina that this might actually be a common occurrence for Gary Hyde-Nic. It only just struck her that there could have been other victims before Sandra and Debra. The next day, Gary took Josefina to buy some clothes from a thrift store and then had her drive behind him in his Cadillac while he took his other car, a Rolls Royce, to the mechanic. During each trip, Josefina kept her focus on the task at hand and avoided making eye contact or conversation with anyone else. She realised Gary was enjoying having her company and decided the smartest thing she could do was continue earning his trust. The more trust he put in her, the greater her chance would be to escape when the right opportunity arose.
在树林里埋尸体是一件平常事。约瑟芬娜第一次意识到，对于加里·海德尼克来说，这可能真的是一件平常事。她突然想到，在桑德拉和黛博拉之前可能还有其他受害者。第二天，加里带约瑟芬娜去一家旧货店买了一些衣服，然后让她开着凯迪拉克跟在他后面，而他则开着另一辆车——劳斯莱斯去修理厂。在每次行程中，约瑟芬娜都专注于手头的任务，避免与任何人进行眼神交流或交谈。她意识到加里很享受她的陪伴，并决定她能做的最明智的事情就是继续赢得他的信任。他越信任她，当合适的时机出现时，她逃脱的机会就越大。
Meanwhile, downstairs in the basement, the conditions had improved slightly for Lisa and Jackie. Gary brought them blankets and pillows and stopped putting them in the hole. He mostly left them alone, although the daily rapes continued. With two of his five victims now dead and only one of them pregnant, Josefina could tell that Gary was getting rattled at the realisation that his twisted plot wasn't going according to plan. By Monday March 23, six days had passed since Deborah's death and Josefina's release from the basement. That night, Gary turned to her and said, I want to get another girl. Josefina saw this as her opening. It was clear to her that Gary now viewed her as an accomplice
与此同时，在楼下的地下室里，丽莎和杰基的处境略有改善。加里给她们拿来了毯子和枕头，也不再把她们关进坑里了。他大部分时间让她们独处，尽管每天的强奸仍在继续。随着他的五名受害者中已有两人死亡，且只有一人怀孕，约瑟芬娜看得出来，加里因为意识到他那扭曲的阴谋没有按计划进行而感到慌乱。到3月23日星期一，距离黛博拉去世和约瑟芬娜从地下室获释已经过去了六天。那天晚上，加里转向她说：“我想再找个女孩。”约瑟芬娜认为这是她的机会。很明显，加里现在把她视为同谋，
and was beginning to let his guard down. She told Gary that she'd help him, but on one condition. After they were done, she wanted to go see her family. Josefina told Gary they'd be worrying about where she'd been these past four months, and she just wanted to introduce them to him so they knew she was okay. Without asking any further questions, Gary agreed. That night, he took Josefina out cruising the streets until they came across a 24-year-old woman named Agnes Adams. Josefina was somewhat familiar with Agnes, having worked with her at the same strip club in the past.
并开始放松警惕。她告诉加里她会帮他，但有一个条件。事情结束后，她想去见见她的家人。约瑟芬娜告诉加里，他们会担心她这四个月去哪儿了，她只是想把他们介绍给他，让他们知道她平安无事。加里没有再问任何问题，就同意了。那天晚上，他带着约瑟芬娜在街上巡游，直到他们遇到了一位名叫艾格尼丝·亚当斯的24岁女子。约瑟芬娜对艾格尼丝有些熟悉，因为过去曾在同一家脱衣舞俱乐部和她一起工作过。
Agnes was a sex worker and she was standing on the street corner looking for clients. When she saw Gary, she waved him over. It turned out that Gary had hired Agnes for sex work in the past. He pulled up alongside Agnes and invited her to come to his house for paid sex work. Seeing Josefina in the passenger seat, Agnes didn't hesitate to hop in. Back at Marshall Street, Josefina waited in the living room while Gary and Agnes went upstairs together. Fifteen minutes later, they returned, this time with Agnes naked in handcuffs. Gary beckoned for Josefina to follow him into the basement.
艾格尼丝是一名性工作者，她站在街角寻找客户。当她看到加里时，她向他招手。原来加里过去曾雇佣过艾格尼丝提供性服务。他把车停在艾格尼丝身边，邀请她去他家进行有偿性交易。看到副驾驶座上的约瑟芬娜，艾格尼丝毫不犹豫地上了车。回到马歇尔街，约瑟芬娜在客厅里等着，而加里和艾格尼丝一起上了楼。十五分钟后，他们回来了，这次艾格尼丝赤身裸体，戴着手铐。加里示意约瑟芬娜跟着他去地下室。
When Lisa and Jackie saw that Josefina had helped Gary abduct a new victim, they looked at her with outright dismay, convinced she was now a willing accomplice. convinced she was now a willing accomplice. Josephina avoided their gaze as Gary chained Agnes up with the muffler clamps and ordered her down into the hole. Josephina then followed Gary back upstairs. He turned to her and said, "...that was easy, we can do that again tomorrow. Now, you want to go see your family? Let's go." Josefina's heart pounded in her chest as Gary steered his Cadillac down Sixth Street toward the corner of Gerrard Street where he'd first picked her up on Thanksgiving Eve almost four months earlier. Josephina indicated a place for Gary to pull over. She told him her family was going to have all kinds of questions and it would be best if she could have some time
当丽莎和杰基看到约瑟芬娜帮助加里绑架了一名新受害者时，她们用极其失望的眼神看着她，确信她现在是一个心甘情愿的同谋。约瑟芬娜避开了她们的目光，加里用消音器夹子把艾格尼丝锁住，并命令她下到坑里。约瑟芬娜随后跟着加里回到楼上。他转向她说：“……那很容易，我们明天可以再做一次。现在，你想去见你的家人吗？我们走吧。”当加里驾驶着凯迪拉克沿着第六街向杰拉德街拐角处驶去时，约瑟芬娜的心在胸腔里怦怦直跳，那是近四个月前感恩节前夕他第一次接她的地方。约瑟芬娜示意加里靠边停车。她告诉他，她的家人会有各种各样的问题，如果她能先和他们单独待一会儿，把事情理顺，那是最好的。
alone with them to smooth things over first. She'd explained to them that Gary was her boyfriend and the two had been away for a while before coming to get him so he could meet everyone too. There was a gas station around the corner where Josefina said he could grab a cup of coffee in the meantime. To her surprise, Gary agreed. To her surprise, Gary agreed. Josephina got out of the car and started making her way as calmly as she could down Gerrard Street. There was a payphone about a block away, and if she could just make it there without arousing his suspicion, this was her one chance. Adrenaline soared as Josefina made it around the corner, the payphone inside. She quickened her pace, terrified that Gary would peer down the street and see what she was up to. Case file will be back shortly.
她会向他们解释加里是她的男朋友，两人已经离开了一段时间，然后再回来接他，这样他也可以见见大家。拐角处有一个加油站，约瑟芬娜说他可以在那儿喝杯咖啡。令她惊讶的是，加里同意了。约瑟芬娜下了车，尽可能冷静地沿着杰拉德街走去。大约一个街区外有一个公用电话，如果她能在不引起他怀疑的情况下到达那里，这就是她唯一的机会。当约瑟芬娜绕过拐角，看到里面的公用电话时，肾上腺素飙升。她加快了脚步，害怕加里会向街头张望并看到她在做什么。案件档案稍后回来。
Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content." Against all odds, Josefina Rivera made it to the payphone, grabbed the receiver and immediately dialled 911. "'You've got to help me,' she told the operator. "'Four months ago I was picked up and held hostage in this guy's basement. He's got three other girls down there.
感谢您通过收听本节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持了Casefile继续提供优质内容。“克服一切困难，约瑟芬娜·里维拉成功到达了公用电话，抓起听筒并立即拨打了911。“你必须救我，”她告诉接线员。“四个月前，我被绑架并被关在这个人的地下室里。他下面还有三个女孩。
I know where he's at and I managed to get away. If he finds out that I'm not coming back, he's going to kill the others. I need someone to come pick him up so he can't get back to the other girls. The operator asked Josefina to repeat herself. It was clear they were having a hard time believing a word she was saying. Regardless, they told Josefina to stay put and that a police car was on its way. The next few minutes felt like hours as Josefina nervously tapped her foot, anxiously waiting for the police to appear while simultaneously keeping an eye out for Gary's Cadillac. Finally, a police car pulled up with two officers inside. Josefina was visibly shaking as she repeated her story, telling the officers she'd been chained
我知道他在哪里，我设法逃了出来。如果他发现我没有回去，他会杀了其他人。我需要有人去把他抓起来，这样他就不能回到其他女孩那里了。”接线员让约瑟芬娜重复一遍。很明显，他们很难相信她说的每一个字。尽管如此，他们还是告诉约瑟芬娜留在原地，警车正在赶来。接下来的几分钟感觉像几个小时，约瑟芬娜紧张地跺着脚，焦急地等待着警察出现，同时还要留意加里的凯迪拉克。终于，一辆警车停了下来，里面有两名警察。约瑟芬娜浑身发抖，重复着她的故事，告诉警察她被一个名叫加里·海德尼克的人关了四个月，
up and repeatedly raped, beaten and tortured for four months by a man named Gary Heidnik, who was at the gas station around the corner. He'd also killed two women and dismembered one of their bodies. The officers urged Josefina to calm down. They asked if she was a sex worker and whether this had something to do with her not getting paid. Exasperated, Josefina pulled up the leg of her jeans to reveal the red raw skin and bruises caused by the shackles. One look at the injuries quelled any of their doubts. Josefina provided a description of Gary and told them where he was parked. The officers sped around the corner, finding him just like she'd described. They ordered Gary to turn off the ignition and get out of the car with his arms on top of his head. He did as he was told, asking, "'What's this all about, officer? Didn't I pay my child's support?' Gary Heidenich
并多次遭到强奸、殴打和折磨，他就在拐角处的加油站。他还杀了两名妇女，并肢解了其中一人的尸体。警察催促约瑟芬娜冷静下来。他们问她是否是性工作者，这是否与她没拿到钱有关。约瑟芬娜愤怒地拉起牛仔裤腿，露出因脚镣造成的红肿皮肤和淤青。看了一眼伤口，他们的怀疑就烟消云散了。约瑟芬娜提供了加里的外貌特征，并告诉他们他停在哪里。警察迅速绕过拐角，发现他正如她所描述的那样。他们命令加里熄火，双手抱头下车。他照做了，问道：“这是怎么回事，警官？我没付子女抚养费吗？”加里·海德尼克
was placed under arrest for rape, kidnapping, aggravated assault, and suspicion of murder. Another officer drove Josefina to the gas station so she could confirm Gary was the right man. That's him, Josefina said. As she later described in the Oxygen Channel documentary, Monster Preacher, the look on Gary's face told her exactly what he was thinking. I really should have gotten rid of this bitch when I had the chance. Josefina was taken back to the sex crimes unit where she told her story in full detail, describing all the depraved acts committed by Gary Heidenich over the past four months. All the while, she continued to ask whether anyone was going back for the other women. Almost five hours passed before a search warrant was issued and orders
因强奸、绑架、严重伤害和谋杀嫌疑被捕。另一名警察开车送约瑟芬娜去加油站，以便她确认加里就是那个人。那是他，约瑟芬娜说。正如她后来在氧气频道纪录片《怪物传教士》中所描述的那样，加里脸上的表情告诉她他到底在想什么。我真该在有机会的时候除掉这个婊子。约瑟芬娜被带回性犯罪部门，在那里她详细讲述了她的故事，描述了加里·海德尼克在过去四个月里犯下的所有堕落行为。在此期间，她不断询问是否有人回去救其他女性。近五个小时过去了，搜查令才签发，命令
were finally given to enter Gary's home on Marshall Street. Police still weren't sure exactly what to make of Josefina's story. It was so rich in detail, yet Gary's home appeared so ordinary, it was hard to comprehend that what she was saying was true. Officers were on edge as they broke Gary's door down with a crowbar and entered the premises. Inside, the heat was cranked to high and a distinct foul odour filled the air. The television and radio blasted at full volume but the house was otherwise quiet. Using a flashlight, officers made their way to the basement where they found Lisa Thomas and Jackie Askins asleep on a mattress on the floor.
终于下达，要求进入加里位于马歇尔街的家中。警方仍然不确定该如何看待约瑟芬娜的故事。它细节如此丰富，但加里的家看起来如此普通，很难理解她所说的是真的。当警察用撬棍撬开加里的门进入屋内时，他们感到紧张。里面暖气开得很高，空气中弥漫着一股明显的恶臭。电视和收音机开得很大声，但房子里却异常安静。警察用手电筒照着路，来到地下室，发现丽莎·托马斯和杰基·阿斯金斯睡在地板上的床垫上。
The two women jumped up in a fright, their blanket dropping to reveal they were naked from the waist down and de-chained at the ankles. Their bodies were bruised, wounded and emaciated. They didn't dare say a word, terrified this could be another of Gary's tests. An officer asked if there were any other women in the house. Lisa and Jackie pointed to the plywood on the floor. The officer pulled it back and out jumped Agnes Adams, naked and handcuffed. It took a moment for the women to realise what was really happening. Lisa and Jackie began jumping up and down, hugging one another and yelling, we're saved. Officers removed the shackles and
两名妇女惊恐地跳了起来，毯子滑落，露出她们腰部以下赤身裸体，脚踝上的锁链已被解开。她们的身体布满淤青、伤口，骨瘦如柴。她们不敢说一句话，害怕这又是加里的又一次考验。一名警察问房子里还有没有其他女性。丽莎和杰基指向地板上的胶合板。警察把它拉开，艾格尼丝·亚当斯跳了出来，赤身裸体，戴着手铐。女人们花了一会儿时间才意识到发生了什么。丽莎和杰基开始跳起来，互相拥抱，大喊：“我们得救了。”警察解开了镣铐，
the three women were led from the house for urgent medical treatment. Neighbours had gathered in the street to see what all the fuss was about and upon seeing the survivors, they began cheering. Josephina, Lisa, Jackie and Agnes were all taken to the hospital to be evaluated. Other than Agnes, who had been held captive less than 24 hours, the others were all severely dehydrated and undernourished. After having their bloods taken, the doctor sat Josephina down and delivered some unexpected yet very welcome news. You're not pregnant, he said. When Lisa Thomas' mother, Paulette Thomas, received the call to say that her daughter was alive and well. She couldn't believe it. As soon as Lisa had failed to return home from her friend's house
三名妇女被带离房子接受紧急医疗救治。邻居们聚集在街上想看看发生了什么事，看到幸存者时，他们开始欢呼。约瑟芬娜、丽莎、杰基和艾格尼丝都被送往医院进行评估。除了被囚禁不到24小时的艾格尼丝外，其他人都有严重的脱水和营养不良。抽血后，医生让约瑟芬娜坐下，并带来了一些意想不到但非常受欢迎的消息。“你没有怀孕，”他说。当丽莎·托马斯的母亲波莱特·托马斯接到电话说她的女儿还活着且安然无恙时，她简直不敢相信。自从丽莎去年12月没能从朋友家回来，
in December the year prior, Paulette knew something was horribly wrong. Lisa was a doting mother to her young son and she would never voluntarily leave him without a good explanation. she would never voluntarily leave him without a good explanation. Paulette had repeatedly called the police to report her daughter missing, but they had dismissed her concerns, saying Lisa was an adult who was free to do as she pleased. Paulette had taken it upon herself to search for her daughter and make her own inquiries. Fearing the worst, she'd even visited the morgue a couple of times. To hear that Lisa was alive after all this time was unbelievable news. When the two were able to speak over the phone from the hospital, the first thing Lisa asked was how her son was doing and whether he was still using his pacifier. Paulette was in awe of her daughter's
波莱特就知道出大事了。丽莎是一个疼爱幼子的母亲，她绝不会在没有合理解释的情况下自愿离开他。波莱特多次报警报告女儿失踪，但他们驳回了她的担忧，称丽莎是一个成年人，可以自由做她想做的事。波莱特决定自己寻找女儿并进行调查。由于担心最坏的情况，她甚至去过停尸房几次。得知丽莎在这么久之后还活着，真是令人难以置信的消息。当两人在医院通过电话交谈时，丽莎问的第一件事就是她儿子怎么样了，他是否还在用安抚奶嘴。波莱特对女儿的
courage, telling reporters, "...the most amazing thing is how tough she is. She's got strong willpower. I wouldn't have held up like she did." For Sandra Lindsay's family, it was a different reaction entirely. Sandra had been incredibly close to her mother and sister, and they'd known something was wrong as soon as she had failed to return home from her trip to buy painkillers the day after Thanksgiving, Saturday November 27, 1986. Although Sandra had a job and lived fairly independently for someone with her intellectual disability, she always checked in with her family with a phone call at least twice a day.
勇气感到敬畏，她告诉记者：“……最令人惊奇的是她有多坚强。她有很强的意志力。我可没法像她那样坚持下来。”对于桑德拉·林赛的家人来说，反应完全不同。桑德拉和她的母亲及姐妹非常亲近，她们在感恩节后的第二天，即1986年11月27日星期六，桑德拉没能从买止痛药的旅途中回家时，就知道出事了。虽然桑德拉有工作，对于一个有智力障碍的人来说生活得相当独立，但她每天至少会给家人打两次电话报平安。
Sandra's family were aware that she sometimes spent time around Gary Heidnik and attended his church sermons on Sundays. She had raved to her sister about all the fun places Gary had taken her and it was clear that she looked up to him. Therefore, one of the first places Sandra's family thought to check after her disappearance was Gary's place, they just weren't sure where he lived. Gary and Sandra had a mutual friend named Cyril Brown who went by the nickname Tony. Like Sandra, Tony had an intellectual disability and spent a lot of time with Gary, having even lived with him for a period of time. Sandra's family asked Tony Brown for Gary's address and phone number, which he readily supplied.
桑德拉的家人知道她有时会和加里·海德尼克在一起，并在周日参加他的教堂布道。她曾向姐姐夸赞加里带她去过的所有有趣的地方，很明显她很敬仰他。因此，桑德拉失踪后，家人想到的第一个检查地点就是加里的住处，只是他们不确定他住在哪里。加里和桑德拉有一位共同的朋友，名叫西里尔·布朗，绰号托尼。和桑德拉一样，托尼也有智力障碍，和加里在一起的时间很多，甚至有一段时间和他住在一起。桑德拉的家人向托尼·布朗询问了加里的地址和电话号码，他很爽快地提供了。
When Sandra's family got to 3520 Marshall Street, they could hear the radio blasting inside. They pounded on the door repeatedly, but Gary didn't answer. Convinced he knew where Sandra was, the family made inquiries with some of the neighbours, who confirmed they'd recently seen Sandra enter the home. When she still hadn't surfaced or made contact by Monday, her family filed a missing person report with the police. They handed over Gary's details. The only thing they weren't sure of was his last name. Gary's details, the only thing they weren't sure of was his last name. A police officer went to 3520 Marshall Street to conduct his own check for Sandra. He heard the radio blaring at full volume inside, but his knocks to the front door went
当桑德拉的家人到达马歇尔街3520号时，他们能听到里面收音机震耳欲聋的声音。他们反复敲门，但加里没有回答。确信他知道桑德拉在哪里，家人向一些邻居打听，邻居们证实他们最近看到桑德拉进了这所房子。当到周一她仍然没有露面或联系时，她的家人向警方提交了一份失踪人员报告。他们交出了加里的详细信息。他们唯一不确定的是他的姓氏。一名警察前往马歇尔街3520号对桑德拉进行检查。他听到里面收音机开得很大声，但他敲前门却
unanswered. The officer tracked down Tony Brown, who confirmed Gary's contact details, including his last name. The officer ran Gary's name through the computer, but nothing came up to indicate he had a prior criminal record. When Sandra's family received a handwritten letter from Sandra a few days later, postmarked from New York in which she claimed to be okay, the officer concluded Sandra was a grown woman who was free to make her own decisions. The police did nothing further to look for her and made no more attempts to enter Gary's home, even when Tony Brown gave Sandra's family some truly bizarre information.
无人应答。警察找到了托尼·布朗，他确认了加里的联系方式，包括他的姓氏。警察在电脑上查询了加里的名字，但没有任何记录表明他有犯罪前科。几天后，当桑德拉的家人收到一封桑德拉手写的信，邮戳显示来自纽约，信中她声称自己很好，警察断定桑德拉是一个成年女性，可以自由做出自己的决定。警方没有进一步寻找她，也没有再尝试进入加里的家，即使托尼·布朗给了桑德拉的家人一些非常离奇的信息。
Tony claimed that he'd kidnapped Sandra on Gary's behalf in exchange for a new car. Gary had then offered Tony $100 to get Sandra pregnant. As Christmas approached, Sandra's mother received a second card from Sandra urging her not to worry. Although her mother recognised the writing as Sandra's, the card contained a $10 bill, money which her mother knew Sandra didn't have access to. Again, she reported these incidents to the officer in charge of Sandra's missing person case, who maintained there was nothing they could do. Even if Sandra was with Gary, they had no evidence that anything criminal had taken place, and they therefore couldn't enter the premises without a
托尼声称他代表加里绑架了桑德拉，以换取一辆新车。加里随后出价100美元让托尼让桑德拉怀孕。随着圣诞节临近，桑德拉的母亲收到了桑德拉的第二张卡片，敦促她不要担心。虽然她的母亲认出笔迹是桑德拉的，但卡片里有一张10美元的钞票，母亲知道桑德拉根本拿不到这种钱。她再次向负责桑德拉失踪案的警官报告了这些事件，但警官坚持认为他们无能为力。即使桑德拉和加里在一起，他们也没有证据表明发生了任何犯罪行为，因此他们无法在没有
search warrant. However, what the officer didn't know at the time was that Tony Brown had accidentally given him the incorrect spelling for Gary's last name. Had this error been identified, the officer would have discovered information that could have saved both Sandra and Deborah's lives. Deborah's lives. The reality was that Gary Heidenick had a criminal record dating back to 1976, beginning with charges for aggravated assault and carrying a firearm without a licence. Most disturbingly was a crime committed in 1978 that should have raised alarm bells, especially given the allegations from Sandra Lindsay's family. By March 1978, Gary Heidnik was in a de facto relationship with an intellectually disabled
搜查令的情况下进入该处。然而，警官当时不知道的是，托尼·布朗不小心给了他加里姓氏的错误拼写。如果这个错误被发现，警官本可以发现能够挽救桑德拉和黛博拉生命的信息。事实是，加里·海德尼克有犯罪记录，可以追溯到1976年，最初的指控是严重伤害和无证携带枪支。最令人不安的是1978年犯下的一项罪行，这本应敲响警钟，特别是考虑到桑德拉·林赛家人的指控。到1978年3月，加里·海德尼克与一名智力障碍的
black woman named Anjanette Davidson and they were living in an apartment in North Philadelphia. The couple had recently welcomed a baby girl, but during Anjanette's pregnancy Gary had insisted on providing her prenatal care himself. This resulted in complications and the baby was put into foster care as soon as she was born. A few weeks later, on Sunday May 7 1978, the couple went to visit Anjanette's sister, Alberta, who lived in a mental health facility. Alberta was 34 years old but with the mentality of a five-year-old and she'd been living in the care facility since she was a teenager. Gary and Ann Jeanette were given the green light to take Alberta out for the day, as
黑人女性安贾内特·戴维森处于事实婚姻关系中，他们住在北费城的一间公寓里。这对夫妇最近迎来了一个女婴，但在安贾内特怀孕期间，加里坚持要亲自为她提供产前护理。这导致了并发症，婴儿一出生就被送进了寄养中心。几周后，即1978年5月7日星期日，这对夫妇去探望住在精神卫生机构的安贾内特的妹妹阿尔伯塔。阿尔伯塔34岁，但心智只有五岁，她从十几岁起就一直住在护理机构。加里和安贾内特获准带阿尔伯塔出去一天，只要
long as she was back the following morning. The next day, Gary called the facility and requested some vacation time for Alberta, and staff there tentatively agreed. Nine days later, Alberta still hadn't returned. A worried staff member went to Gary's apartment looking for her, but Gary claimed he'd put Alberta on a bus back to the facility days earlier and a search of his home turned up no sign of her. The next day, the staff member returned with a police officer who searched the entire building. They found a terrified Alberta cowering in an old storage room in the basement showing signs of trauma and sexual assault. Gary was charged with kidnapping, rape,
她第二天早上能回来就行。第二天，加里打电话给该机构，要求为阿尔伯塔请几天假，工作人员勉强同意了。九天后，阿尔伯塔仍然没有回来。一名担心的工作人员去加里的公寓找她，但加里声称他几天前就把阿尔伯塔送上了回机构的巴士，对他的家进行搜查后也没有发现她的踪迹。第二天，工作人员带着一名警察回来，搜查了整栋大楼。他们在地下室的一个旧储藏室里发现了惊恐万状的阿尔伯塔，她表现出创伤和性侵犯的迹象。加里被控绑架、强奸、
false imprisonment and involuntary deviant sexual intercourse, among other crimes. He pleaded not guilty, claiming Alberta had asked to stay with them because she was being mistreated at the care facility. Due to her intellectual disability, Alberta was deemed unable to testify in court. Gary was therefore convicted of several lesser crimes, including unlawful restraint and recklessly endangering another person. The judge concluded that Gary was psychosexually immature, unable to tolerate criticism, in constant need of external validation and, quote, easily threatened by women whom he would consider to be equal to him either intellectually or emotionally. The judge gave the highest sentence possible of three to seven years,
非法监禁和非自愿变态性行为等罪名。他拒不认罪，声称阿尔伯塔要求和他们住在一起，因为她在护理机构受到了虐待。由于她的智力障碍，阿尔伯塔被认为无法在法庭上作证。因此，加里因几项较轻的罪名被定罪，包括非法拘禁和鲁莽危害他人安全。法官得出结论，加里在心理性方面不成熟，无法容忍批评，不断需要外部认可，并且“容易受到他认为在智力或情感上与他平等的女性的威胁”。法官判处了最高刑期，即三到七年，
which Gary appealed. A subsequent psychological report stated that Gary Hydenick had a proclivity to exploit and manipulate intellectually disabled black women, both financially and sexually, as it gave him a sense of authority to be in charge of more vulnerable individuals. The psychiatrist predicted that Gary would go on to commit further sexual assaults in the future, stating forebodingly, "...in order to avoid such a tragedy in the future, stating forebodingly, In order to avoid such a tragedy in the future, it will be necessary for him to be very closely supervised, and for him to receive continuing surveillance over a long period of time. For the next two and a half years, Gary served his prison sentence in silence, claiming he was unable to speak because the devil had shoved a cookie down his throat. He was released on parole five years later in March 1983.
加里对此提出了上诉。随后的心理报告指出，加里·海德尼克有剥削和操纵智力障碍黑人女性的倾向，无论是在经济上还是在性方面，因为这让他有一种掌控更脆弱个体的权威感。精神科医生预测加里未来会继续犯下性侵罪，并预言性地指出：“为了避免未来发生这样的悲剧，有必要对他进行非常严密的监督，并让他长期接受持续的监视。”在接下来的两年半里，加里在沉默中服刑，声称他无法说话，因为魔鬼把一块饼干塞进了他的喉咙。五年后的1983年3月，他获得假释。
Shortly after, he joined the Filipino matchmaking service and began corresponding with his future wife, Betty. The two got to know one another via letters and phone calls for almost two years before Betty finally flew to the United States to meet Gary in person. They were married days later, but the honeymoon period was short-lived. Within a week, Gary started bringing home other women, sometimes several at a time. They were always black and typically sex workers or patients from the Elwyn Institute. Betty said she'd leave, but Gary constantly beat and raped her, threatening to kill her if she ran away. Three and a half months after arriving at Marshall Street in late January 1986, Betty said she was going out shopping and ran straight to the police instead. Betty filed charges against Gary for spousal rape, indecent assault, and involuntary deviant sexual intercourse. The charges just happened to
不久之后，他加入了菲律宾婚介服务，并开始与未来的妻子贝蒂通信。两人通过信件和电话互相了解了近两年，贝蒂才终于飞往美国与加里见面。几天后他们结婚了，但蜜月期很短暂。一周之内，加里就开始带其他女人回家，有时一次带好几个。她们总是黑人，通常是性工作者或埃尔温研究所的病人。贝蒂说她要离开，但加里不断地殴打和强奸她，威胁说如果她逃跑就杀了她。1986年1月底到达马歇尔街三个半月后，贝蒂说她要去购物，结果直接跑向了警察局。贝蒂对加里提出了配偶强奸、猥亵和非自愿变态性行为的指控。这些指控恰好
be laid two days after Gary's parole ended for his crimes against Alberta Davidson, which was unfortunate timing as it meant he wasn't in breach of his parole conditions. Unbeknown to Gary, Betty was also pregnant. After the child was born, Betty sued Gary for child support, and they both appeared in the family court in January 1987. Gary lied about his substantial assets, saying he'd spent the profits from his investments and the only money he had was from his disability pension. Convinced that Gary was being intentionally evasive, the judge promised Betty another hearing once he'd had the chance to do some further investigation. Meanwhile, as he sat in court lying openly, Gary was holding four women captive in
在加里因对阿尔伯塔·戴维森犯罪而获得的假释期结束两天后提出，这很不凑巧，因为这意味着他没有违反假释条件。加里不知道的是，贝蒂也怀孕了。孩子出生后，贝蒂起诉加里要求子女抚养费，两人于1987年1月出现在家庭法院。加里谎报了自己的巨额资产，说他已经花光了投资收益，他唯一的钱来自残疾抚养金。法官确信加里在故意逃避，承诺贝蒂一旦有机会进行进一步调查，就会再举行一次听证会。与此同时，当他坐在法庭上公然撒谎时，加里正将四名女性囚禁在
his basement. Sandra Lindsay's family had managed to track Betty down in their hunt for Sandra and learned about Gary's deviant sexual practices and history of holding women captive. Sandra's family told the police about this, but they found themselves at yet another roadblock. After Betty's escape, she'd been so terrified of Gary that she'd failed to appear in court and the charges against him had been subsequently dropped. The police promised Sandra's family that they'd apply for a search warrant for Gary's house, but they never did, closing the missing person investigation instead. With the help of Josefina Rivera, Deborah Dudley's remains were recovered from New Jersey
他的地下室里。桑德拉·林赛的家人在寻找桑德拉的过程中设法找到了贝蒂，并了解了加里的变态性行为和囚禁女性的历史。桑德拉的家人告诉了警察，但他们又遇到了另一个障碍。贝蒂逃跑后，她对加里感到非常恐惧，以至于没有出庭，针对他的指控随后被撤销。警察向桑德拉的家人承诺，他们会申请搜查加里房子的搜查令，但他们从未这样做，反而结案了失踪人员调查。在约瑟芬娜·里维拉的帮助下，黛博拉·达德利的遗骸从新泽西州被找回，
and returned to Philadelphia. Forensic investigators also recovered what they could of Sandra Lindsay's dismembered remains from Marshall Street, including her skull from the stovetop, ribcage from the oven, and arms and legs from the freezer. With the available evidence and testimony from the surviving women, Gary Heidenich was charged with more than 50 crimes, including two counts of murder, kidnapping, rape, aggravated assault, false imprisonment, involuntary deviant sexual intercourse, unlawful restraint, indecent exposure, and abuse of a corpse. With Gary's crimes making headlines across the United States, members of the public were curious to know more about his background and upbringing.
并送回费城。法医调查人员还从马歇尔街找回了桑德拉·林赛被肢解的遗骸，包括炉灶上的头骨、烤箱里的胸腔，以及冰柜里的手臂和腿。凭借现有的证据和幸存女性的证词，加里·海德尼克被控50多项罪名，包括两项谋杀罪、绑架、强奸、严重伤害、非法监禁、非自愿变态性行为、非法拘禁、猥亵暴露和亵渎尸体。随着加里的罪行在美国各地成为头条新闻，公众成员很想了解更多关于他的背景和成长经历。
states, members of the public were curious to know more about his background and upbringing. Following his arrest for the crimes against Alberta Davidson in 1978, Gary had told a court-appointed investigator that his childhood was marred by trauma. He said that his father was a racist who hated his mother because she had multiple affairs with black men. Gary alleged that his father had beaten him frequently during his youth and offered no love or emotional support. Gary frequently wet the bed and when he did so, his father would force him to hang his soiled sheets out of his bedroom window so the whole neighbourhood would know. These claims were supported by Gary's
公众成员很想了解更多关于他的背景和成长经历。在1978年因对阿尔伯塔·戴维森犯罪被捕后，加里曾告诉法庭指定的调查员，他的童年充满了创伤。他说他的父亲是一个种族主义者，讨厌他的母亲，因为她与黑人男子有多次外遇。加里声称他的父亲在年轻时经常殴打他，没有提供任何爱或情感支持。加里经常尿床，当他这样做时，他的父亲会强迫他把弄脏的床单挂在卧室窗外，让整个社区都知道。这些说法得到了加里
younger brother, Terry, who spoke to reporters from the Philadelphia Inquirer in detail following Gary's arrest in 1987. Terry said that Gary chose black women because he felt a need to dominate them and intellectually disabled women because he thought they were easier to control. Terry said their father had taught them that, quote, life has no value if it is a black life, and that although Gary didn't outwardly express it, he adopted their father's racist attitudes. it, he adopted their father's racist attitudes. Along with the beatings, Terry also claimed that their father would paint bullseyes on the back of their pants so that other kids at school would target them too. According to Terry, when Gary was a child he fell from a tree which caused his head
弟弟特里的支持，他在1987年加里被捕后详细接受了《费城问询报》记者的采访。特里说，加里选择黑人女性是因为他觉得有必要支配她们，选择智力障碍女性是因为他认为她们更容易控制。特里说，他们的父亲教导他们说：“如果是一个黑人的生命，那么生命就没有价值。”虽然加里没有公开表达出来，但他采纳了他父亲的种族主义态度。除了殴打，特里还声称他们的父亲会在他们的裤子后面画靶心，这样学校里的其他孩子也会针对他们。据特里说，加里小时候从树上摔下来，导致他的头部
to become permanently misshapen. After that, Gary's behaviour changed significantly. He became violent and was increasingly seeking his father's approval. Terry stated, Gary spent his whole childhood trying to be the light of my father's eyes. the light of my father's eyes." He said that being accepted by their father was, quote, probably what my brother was looking for his whole life. Terry explained that he and Gary were eventually sent to live with their mother, but she had a string of failed relationships and marriages and also struggled with alcohol addiction, which further added to their instability. Gary and Terry eventually joined the army but were both discharged after being diagnosed with schizophrenia. Their mother eventually took her own life and they lost contact
永久变形。那之后，加里的行为发生了显著变化。他变得暴力，并越来越寻求父亲的认可。特里说：“加里整个童年都在努力成为我父亲眼中的光。”他说，被父亲接受是“我哥哥一生都在寻找的东西”。特里解释说，他和加里最终被送去和母亲住在一起，但她有一连串失败的感情和婚姻，还与酒精成瘾作斗争，这进一步增加了他们的不稳定。加里和特里最终参军，但都被诊断出患有精神分裂症后退伍。他们的母亲最终自杀了，他们也失去了与
with their father. Gary and Terry's father Michael Hytenick denied claims of childhood abuse. In 1978 he told the court-appointed investigator that Gary had shown signs of mental illness since he was a young boy and that he'd disowned Gary completely in the 1960s after discovering that he was living with a black woman. However, when speaking to the Philadelphia Inquirer during a phone interview following Gary's arrest in 1987, his story differed. While Michael upheld that he'd disowned and disinherited Gary, he said that had nothing to do with his involvement with a black woman. Michael denied being racist, stating he wouldn't care if Gary lived with a black woman, adding,
父亲的联系。加里和特里的父亲迈克尔·海德尼克否认了童年虐待的指控。1978年，他告诉法庭指定的调查员，加里从小就表现出精神疾病的迹象，并且他在1960年代发现加里与一名黑人女性同居后，就彻底与加里断绝了关系。然而，在1987年加里被捕后接受《费城问询报》的电话采访时，他的说法有所不同。虽然迈克尔坚持说他已经与加里断绝关系并剥夺了他的继承权，但他表示这与他与黑人女性的交往无关。迈克尔否认自己是种族主义者，称他不在乎加里是否与黑人女性同居，并补充说，
quote, I don't care if he lived with ten of them. But there was one thing that both Terry and Michael Hydenick could agree on. When they first heard about the crimes Gary had been accused of, Terry said, "...I believed it right off the bat. Gary was very capable of that." Michael told USA Today that his son should be hanged, adding, "...I'll even pull the rope." adding, "'I'll even pull the rope.'" Execution was a very real possibility for Gary Hyde-Nick, with the state of Pennsylvania offering the death penalty for anyone found guilty of first-degree murder. Given the mountain of evidence against him, including testimony from the four women who
“我不在乎他是否和十个这样的女人住在一起。”但特里和迈克尔·海德尼克有一点是可以达成共识的。当他们第一次听说加里被指控的罪行时，特里说：“……我立刻就相信了。加里完全有能力做出那种事。”迈克尔告诉《今日美国》，他的儿子应该被绞死，并补充说：“……我甚至会去拉绳子。”对加里·海德尼克来说，死刑是一个非常现实的可能性，宾夕法尼亚州对任何被判一级谋杀罪的人都处以死刑。鉴于对他不利的大量证据，包括四名女性的证词，
survived the ordeal, Gary's defence team knew there was no way their client could escape the charges. Instead, they put forward a plea of not guilty by reason of insanity. After all, Gary had a detailed medical record citing mental illness, which dated back to 1963 when he was discharged from the army. While he'd initially been given a 10% disability pension, this had increased over the years to 100%. Such a payment was reserved only for individuals who were unable to function normally in the community and demonstrated quote, gross repudiation of reality. If the defence could prove that Gary wasn't of sound mind at the time he committed the crimes and couldn't tell right
幸存者们知道，他们的当事人不可能逃脱指控。相反，他们提出了因精神错乱而无罪的辩护。毕竟，加里有详细的医疗记录，记录了他的精神疾病，可以追溯到1963年他从军队退伍时。虽然他最初获得了10%的残疾抚养金，但多年来这一比例已增加到100%。这种赔偿仅保留给那些无法在社区中正常生活并表现出“对现实的严重否定”的个人。如果辩护方能证明加里在犯罪时精神不正常，无法分辨是非，
from wrong, at the very least they hoped to secure a conviction of third degree murder. Under Pennsylvania law, this would mean the deaths of Sandra Lindsay and Deborah Dudley weren't intentional. Gary's state of mind at the time of the crimes formed the entire basis of the defense's argument when the case went to trial in June 1988. The defense led testimony from two psychiatrists, the first of whom, Dr Clancy McKenzie, introduced a controversial theory. He believed that all patients with schizophrenia had two minds, one of the adult and one of their troubled infant self. Dr McKenzie explained that in the key period of November 1986 to March 1987, Gary was operating under what he called an infant brain. Gary was just 17 months old at the time his mother gave birth to his brother, Terry.
他们至少希望获得三级谋杀罪的判决。根据宾夕法尼亚州法律，这意味着桑德拉·林赛和黛博拉·达德利的死亡并非蓄意。当案件于1988年6月开庭审理时，加里在犯罪时的精神状态构成了辩护方论点的全部基础。辩方引导了两名精神科医生的证词，其中第一位，克兰西·麦肯齐博士，引入了一个有争议的理论。他认为所有精神分裂症患者都有两个头脑，一个是成人的，一个是他们困扰的婴儿自我的。麦肯齐博士解释说，在1986年11月至1987年3月的关键时期，加里是在他所谓的婴儿大脑下运作的。加里在母亲生下弟弟特里时只有17个月大。
When Gary's estranged wife, Betty, revealed to him in October 1986 that she'd given birth to their son, Dr Mackenzie concluded, quote, This took him back to the first time when the most important woman in the world to him, his mother, left him and had a baby. And at that point, he began to experience the world through the eyes of the 17-month-old. The reality is that mummy is never going to go away and leave me again. During that four to five month period he could not have known right from wrong. The second psychiatrist disagreed with Dr Mackenzie's theory, clarifying his belief
当加里分居的妻子贝蒂在1986年10月向他透露她生下了他们的儿子时，麦肯齐博士得出结论：“这让他回到了第一次，当时对他来说世界上最重要的女人——他的母亲——离开了他并生了一个孩子。在那一刻，他开始通过17个月大的孩子的眼睛看世界。现实是，妈妈永远不会再离开我了。在那四到五个月的时间里，他不可能分辨是非。”第二位精神科医生不同意麦肯齐博士的理论，澄清了他的信念，
that schizophrenia was primarily a genetic mental illness from which Gary had a long-standing battle. He testified that Gary's schizophrenia affected him in such a manner that he was unable to tell the difference between right and wrong. He concluded that Gary was delusional and that the crimes he committed were part of a quote, systematised delusion that God wanted him to produce a number of children, and this was essentially to him like a pact with God.
即精神分裂症主要是一种遗传性精神疾病，加里长期以来一直在与之抗争。他作证说，加里的精神分裂症以这样一种方式影响了他，使他无法分辨是非。他得出结论，加里有妄想症，他犯下的罪行是“系统性妄想”的一部分，即上帝希望他生下许多孩子，这对他来说本质上就像是与上帝的契约。
While he was somewhat aware of the laws he was breaking, he saw God's law as superior and didn't have the mental capacity to differentiate between the two. The prosecution didn't argue that Gary had schizophrenia. Their case centred around the belief that his cognitive ability was fully intact during the time he committed the crimes and he knew full well that what he was doing was wrong. After all, if he was so insane, how did he continue to successfully manage his stock portfolio or negotiate the purchase of a Cadillac. The prosecution put forward that Gary had long been exaggerating the symptoms of his mental illness so that he could continue receiving disability
虽然他多少意识到自己正在触犯法律，但他认为上帝的法律高于一切，没有心理能力来区分两者。检方并没有争辩加里患有精神分裂症。他们的案件集中在这样一个信念上：他在犯罪期间认知能力完全正常，并且非常清楚自己在做的事情是错误的。毕竟，如果他真的那么疯狂，他怎么能继续成功地管理他的股票投资组合或协商购买凯迪拉克呢？检方提出，加里长期以来一直在夸大他的精神疾病症状，以便继续领取残疾
benefits. Pre-trial testing had revealed Gary to have an IQ of over 130, which put him in the top 1% of the population for intellect. This, combined with his training as a psychiatric nurse, meant he knew exactly what to do to make others question his sanity. During Josefina Rivera's time in captivity, Gary had allegedly told her that if he was ever arrested he would simply act crazy in court until his case was eventually thrown out. The prosecution put forth that this was exactly what he was doing. Gary had refused to say a word to their court-appointed forensic psychiatrist, instead pretending to be incapable of speech, and when he entered the courtroom he'd made the
福利。审前测试显示加里的智商超过130，这使他处于人口智力水平的前1%。这加上他作为精神科护士的培训，意味着他非常清楚该怎么做才能让别人质疑他的理智。在约瑟芬娜·里维拉被囚禁期间，加里据称告诉她，如果他被捕，他只会简单地在法庭上装疯卖傻，直到他的案件最终被驳回。检方提出，这正是他正在做的事情。加里拒绝与他们法庭指定的法医精神科医生说一句话，而是假装无法说话，当他进入法庭时，他做出了
odd move of saluting the judge. While witnesses testified that Gary had always been typically clean-cut, in court he appeared dishevelled with a long, unkempt beard and wore the same Hawaiian shirt and tan pants every day. The judge had even issued a court order forcing him to bathe before his trial after it was revealed that he hadn't showered for well over a month. The prosecution presented various witnesses who had dealings with Gary Hyde-Nick around the time he was holding the women captive, such as his car dealer, stockbroker, friends, and medical professionals. All testified that Gary was his usual self during the key period between November 1986 and March 1987, and he wasn't suffering from any obvious delusions of
向法官敬礼的怪异举动。虽然证人作证说加里一直以来都打扮得干净利落，但在法庭上，他却显得衣衫不整，留着长而凌乱的胡须，每天都穿着同一件夏威夷衬衫和棕褐色裤子。法官甚至在得知他已经一个多月没洗澡后，下达了强制他在审判前洗澡的法庭令。检方传唤了多名在加里·海德尼克囚禁女性期间与他有过往来的证人，例如他的汽车经销商、股票经纪人、朋友和医疗专业人员。所有人都作证说，在1986年11月至1987年3月的关键时期，加里的表现与往常无异，并没有表现出任何明显的
grandeur or hallucinations. On the contrary, he'd appeared clean, courteous, rational, and intelligent. During his January 1987 appearance in the family court, his behaviour was described as cunning and deceptive when it came to answering questions about his true monetary worth, so as to diminish his obligations to support his wife and infant son. The forensic psychiatrist who reviewed Gary's extensive medical history, business records, police interviews, and witness testimony for the prosecution, concluded that while Gary did indeed have schizophrenia, he was manipulative and exaggerated his mental illness.
夸大妄想或幻觉。相反，他看起来干净、礼貌、理智且聪明。在1987年1月出庭家事法庭时，他在回答关于其真实经济状况的问题时，被描述为狡猾和具有欺骗性，目的是为了减少他抚养妻子和幼子的义务。为检方审查了加里详尽病史、商业记录、警方访谈和证人证词的法医精神科医生得出结论：虽然加里确实患有精神分裂症，但他具有操纵性，并夸大了自己的精神疾病。
The psychiatrist concluded that Gary's cognitive ability was intact between November 1986 and March 1987, stating, "...there is nothing to indicate that Gary Hydenick did not know what he was doing was wrong at the time he was doing was wrong at the time he was doing it. The trial ran for two weeks before the defence presented their closing argument, urging the jury to consider the lesser conviction of third degree murder. Gary's lawyer stated, The question is not whether Gary Hydenic did these heinous acts, but whether or not he was insane.
精神科医生得出结论，加里在1986年11月至1987年3月期间认知能力完好，并指出：“……没有任何迹象表明加里·海德尼克在做这些事时不知道自己在做错事。”审判进行了两周，辩方才进行结案陈词，敦促陪审团考虑三级谋杀这一较轻的罪名。加里的律师表示：“问题不在于加里·海德尼克是否犯下了这些令人发指的罪行，而在于他是否精神失常。”
Let's say he's a malingerer, a faker, that he went into the army with plans to develop a paranoid schizophrenic personality so one day he could make a living that way. Could he fool all those doctors all the time? Could he fake mental illness schizophrenia for 25 years? You have to believe that. You have to believe he did this for 25 years so when he got caught building his family in his basement he could say he was insane. That's the prosecution's case. Does that make sense? His purpose was to raise 10 kids, not to kill anybody. Third degree murder is reckless disregard for human life. This is a classic case of third degree. As for the fact that Gary had chosen an intellectually disabled woman and sex workers to be his victims, the lawyer stated, quote,
假设他是一个装病者、一个骗子，他参军是为了计划培养出偏执型精神分裂症人格，这样有一天他就能以此为生。他能一直欺骗所有那些医生吗？他能伪装精神分裂症长达25年吗？你必须相信这一点。你必须相信他为了在被抓到在地下室建立家庭时能说自己精神失常，而演了25年的戏。这就是检方的论点。这说得通吗？他的目的是抚养10个孩子，而不是杀人。三级谋杀是对人类生命鲁莽的漠视。这是一个经典的三级谋杀案例。至于加里选择智障女性和性工作者作为受害者这一事实，律师引用道：
As sick as it is, these were his chosen people. These were the girls he wanted to reproduce with. Is that sane? Isn't it more likely he's insane than not? In rebuttal, the prosecution told the jury that while none of the experts could read Gary's mind to confirm whether or not he was lying, the bottom line was, quote, This man repeated sadistic and malicious acts upon six victims. He planned it, he did it, and he concealed it. Make no mistake about it, this man committed murder in the first degree.
尽管这很病态，但这些人是他选择的对象。这些是他想要与之繁衍后代的女性。这算精神正常吗？难道他精神失常的可能性不是更大吗？在反驳中，检方告诉陪审团，虽然没有任何专家能读懂加里的心思来确认他是否在撒谎，但底线是，引用：“这个人对六名受害者反复实施了虐待和恶意行为。他策划了这一切，实施了这一切，并掩盖了这一切。毫无疑问，这个人犯下了一级谋杀罪。”
It's clear that Sandra Lindsay and Deborah Dudley were killed as a result of being taken into that basement. It's clear that Gary Heidenich did it. It was premeditated. It was deliberate. It was intentional. Members of the jury deliberated for two and a half days before delivering their verdict. Guilty on all counts, including murder in the first degree for the deaths of Sandra Lindsay and Deborah Dudley. Under Pennsylvania law, it was also up to the jury to decide the penalty, life imprisonment or execution. The jury deliberated for less than two hours before delivering this verdict. For the murders of Sandra and Debra, Gary Heidenich would be sentenced to death. The conclusion of Gary's trial didn't mark the end
很明显，桑德拉·林赛和黛博拉·达德利是因为被带进那个地下室而丧命的。很明显是加里·海德尼克干的。这是预谋的。这是蓄意的。这是故意的。陪审团成员经过两天半的审议后作出了裁决。所有罪名成立，包括对桑德拉·林赛和黛博拉·达德利的一级谋杀罪。根据宾夕法尼亚州法律，陪审团还需决定刑罚，是终身监禁还是死刑。陪审团在不到两小时的审议后作出了裁决。因谋杀桑德拉和黛博拉，加里·海德尼克被判处死刑。加里审判的结束并不标志着
of the case. The day after Gary was initially arrested, his friend Tony Brown, who was also an associate of Sandra's, had walked into the police station to see what was going on. Tony introduced himself as Gary's best friend and former housemate, which immediately aroused police interest. Tony was interrogated for 18 hours, during which he made some startling assertions. He revealed that this wasn't the first time Gary had held women captive. Tony claimed that in the summer of 1985, Gary had offered a sex worker hundreds of dollars to come back to his house. The next morning, Tony went into the basement to do some laundry and found the woman there bound in chains. She asked Tony to let her out, but he was too
案件的终结。在加里最初被捕的第二天，他的朋友托尼·布朗（也是桑德拉的熟人）走进警察局想看看发生了什么事。托尼自称是加里最好的朋友和前室友，这立即引起了警方的兴趣。托尼被审讯了18个小时，期间他做出了一些惊人的断言。他透露，这并不是加里第一次囚禁女性。托尼声称，1985年夏天，加里曾出价数百美元让一名性工作者回到他家。第二天早上，托尼去地下室洗衣服，发现那个女人被锁链锁在那里。她请求托尼放她走，但他太
scared of what Gary might do, so he left her there. A week later, a hideous stench filled the house. later a hideous stench filled their house. Tony claimed he found Gary dismembering the woman's body parts which he then buried in his front yard. This aligned with information from the surviving victims who told the police that Gary had bragged to some of them about having killed up to six other women. A full excavation was done of the Marshall Street property, but no other human remains were found. However, Tony Brown wasn't done talking. He also claims that on the day Sandra Lindsay died, Tony himself had been in the basement. Tony said he'd watched Gary force the bread into Sandra's mouth before she presumably choked to death. Afterwards, Tony claimed he helped Gary carry Sandra's body upstairs, where Gary later raped her corpse. For this confession, Tony Brown was also
害怕加里会对他做什么，所以就把她留在了那里。一周后，房子里弥漫着一股恶臭。托尼声称他发现加里正在肢解那个女人的尸体，然后将其埋在院子里。这与幸存受害者的信息相吻合，她们告诉警方，加里曾向其中一些人吹嘘自己杀害了多达六名其他女性。警方对马歇尔街的房产进行了全面挖掘，但没有发现其他人类遗骸。然而，托尼·布朗并没有说完。他还声称在桑德拉·林赛去世的那天，他本人也在地下室。托尼说他看着加里把面包强塞进桑德拉的嘴里，直到她大概窒息而死。之后，托尼声称他帮加里把桑德拉的尸体搬到楼上，加里后来强奸了她的尸体。因为这份供词，托尼·布朗也被
charged with Sandra Lindsay's murder, as well as conspiracy, kidnapping and rape. The problem with Tony's confession was, none of the surviving women backed his story up. They claimed they'd never seen Tony Brown in the basement, and he certainly wasn't there the day Sandra Lindsay died. Due to his intellectual disability, during his early court proceedings, Tony had difficulty understanding basic questions and couldn't even state his own name. His defence attorney told reporters, quote, Mr Brown was victimised to the same extent as the women involved, although he was not hurt.
指控犯有桑德拉·林赛的谋杀罪，以及共谋、绑架和强奸罪。托尼供词的问题在于，没有一个幸存女性支持他的说法。她们声称从未在地下室见过托尼·布朗，而且桑德拉·林赛去世那天他肯定不在那里。由于智力障碍，在早期的法庭诉讼中，托尼难以理解基本问题，甚至无法说出自己的名字。他的辩护律师告诉记者：“布朗先生和涉案女性一样受到了伤害，尽管他没有受伤。”
Brown fits the profile of each and every victim. Given there was no evidence to support them, the charges against Tony Brown were ultimately dropped. However, Tony wasn't the only one who came under the spotlight as a potential accomplice. Another controversial opinion had arisen during Gary's trial when his defence lawyer raised the possibility of charging Josefina Rivera as an accomplice to Gary's crimes. The judge had warned against this on the grounds that it could hurt their insanity defence, stating, "...if the defendant is clever enough to enlist the aid of an accomplice, he knows what he's doing." The defence stopped short of pressing for charges,
布朗符合每一位受害者的特征。鉴于没有证据支持这些指控，针对托尼·布朗的指控最终被撤销。然而，托尼并不是唯一一个作为潜在同谋受到关注的人。在加里的审判中，当他的辩护律师提出将约瑟芬娜·里维拉作为加里罪行的同谋进行指控的可能性时，出现了另一种有争议的观点。法官对此提出了警告，理由是这可能会损害他们的精神失常辩护，并指出：“……如果被告聪明到能招募同谋的帮助，那他就知道自己在做什么。”辩方没有坚持提出指控，
but they did urge the jury to consider Josefina's impact on their client's behaviour, saying that she was, quote, feeding a sick mind. They argued that Josephina led Gary to believe that what he was doing was okay, and this gave him the corroboration he needed to keep going. The other surviving women, Lisa Thomas, Jackie Askins, and Agnes Adams, agreed that Josefina was complicit to some extent. They struggled to understand how she could have aided in Deborah's death and helped kidnap Agnes knowing what she was about to endure.
但他们确实敦促陪审团考虑约瑟芬娜对他们当事人行为的影响，称她是在“喂养一个病态的心灵”。他们辩称，约瑟芬娜让加里相信他所做的一切是没问题的，这给了他继续下去所需的佐证。其他幸存女性——丽莎·托马斯、杰基·阿斯金斯和艾格尼丝·亚当斯——都认为约瑟芬娜在某种程度上是共犯。她们无法理解她怎么能协助导致黛博拉的死亡，并在明知艾格尼丝即将遭受什么的情况下帮助绑架了她。
Given that Josefina was the oldest of the group, they felt it was her responsibility to protect them, not cause them further harm. Jackie later told the documentary Monster Preacher, Even though Josefina was in a bad situation, she was still supposed to protect us. At the end of the day, Philadelphia made her a hero. For who? For us? No. She wasn't a hero for me.
鉴于约瑟芬娜是这群人中年龄最大的，她们觉得保护她们是她的责任，而不是给她们造成进一步的伤害。杰基后来在纪录片《怪物传教士》中说：“即使约瑟芬娜处境糟糕，她本也应该保护我们。归根结底，费城把她塑造成了英雄。为了谁？为了我们？不。她对我来说不是英雄。”
Even members of the jury later said they believed Josefina was more culpable than was presented, but many others disagreed. Renowned criminal behaviour analyst Laura Richards told the show Killer Profile that Gary had learned through his childhood that people could be controlled using abuse, ridicule, and beatings. When Gary started to trust Josephina, that's when he began to lose his power. Laura said, "...he's the great manipulator, but ultimately, Josefina wins on the manipulation level of getting him to trust her." Josefina went on to write a book about her experience titled Seller Girl, in which she made it clear that her intentions were always to make sure the women got out of the basement alive.
甚至陪审团成员后来也表示，他们认为约瑟芬娜的罪责比表现出来的要大，但许多人不同意。著名犯罪行为分析师劳拉·理查兹在节目《杀手档案》中表示，加里在童年时期就学会了人们可以通过虐待、嘲笑和殴打来控制。当加里开始信任约瑟芬娜时，他才开始失去权力。劳拉说：“……他是伟大的操纵者，但最终，约瑟芬娜在让他信任她的操纵层面上赢了。”约瑟芬娜后来写了一本关于她经历的书，名为《地窖女孩》，她在书中明确表示，她的意图始终是确保这些女性活着走出地下室。
her intentions were always to make sure the women got out of the basement alive. Josefina was so traumatised by the ordeal that she was unable to regain custody of her children, and she spent years continuing to struggle with substance abuse disorder to escape the pain of it all. She later told the Daily Mirror, "...you don't ever totally get over an experience like mine. You just have to learn to live with it." Gary Hyde-Nich sat on death row for 11 years, saying he had no intentions of appealing his sentence. Regardless, an appellate review was mandatory under Pennsylvania law and a forensic psychiatrist was appointed by the court to interview Gary. Gary stated he wanted the
她的意图始终是确保这些女性活着走出地下室。约瑟芬娜因这段经历而受到严重创伤，以至于无法重新获得孩子的监护权，并且多年来一直与药物滥用障碍作斗争，以逃避这一切带来的痛苦。她后来告诉《每日镜报》：“……你永远无法完全从像我这样的经历中走出来。你只能学会与它共存。”加里·海德尼克在死囚牢房里待了11年，称他无意对判决提出上诉。无论如何，根据宾夕法尼亚州法律，上诉审查是强制性的，法院指派了一名法医精神科医生来采访加里。加里表示他希望
execution to go ahead because, quote, I am innocent and I can prove it. When you execute an innocent man there will be no more capital punishment in this state and possibly anywhere else in this country. Go ahead and execute me. That's the end of capital punishment." Gary's lawyers said that his willingness to be executed was further proof that he wasn't of sound mind, but the psychiatrist concluded that Gary understood fully and was just trying to put a good spin on a bad ending. The sentence was upheld and the execution was scheduled for Tuesday July 6 1999. As the time loomed near, news that the execution would be going ahead sparked hot debate among
执行死刑，因为：“我是无辜的，我可以证明。当你处决一个无辜的人时，这个州乃至这个国家的任何地方都不会再有死刑了。继续执行吧。这就是死刑的终结。”加里的律师说，他愿意被处决进一步证明他精神不正常，但精神科医生得出结论，加里完全理解这一点，只是试图给一个糟糕的结局披上一层好听的外衣。判决被维持，执行日期定于1999年7月6日星期二。随着时间临近，执行死刑的消息在
those who were against the death penalty. Protesters gathered outside the governor's home until the final orders were given that evening. 55-year-old Gary Heidenick ate a final meal of two slices of cheese pita and two cups of black coffee before being led to the execution chamber just before 10pm. He had no last words as he was strapped to the gurney and administered with a lethal injection. With Gary declared dead, applause rang out among the witnesses gathered. Thank you Jesus, one cried out. Josefina Rivera, Lisa Thomas, Agnes Adams, and Jackie Askins weren't among them.
反对死刑的人群中引发了激烈的辩论。抗议者聚集在州长家外，直到那天晚上收到最终命令。55岁的加里·海德尼克吃了最后一顿饭——两片奶酪皮塔饼和两杯黑咖啡，随后在晚上10点前被带往行刑室。他在被绑在担架上并注射致命药物时没有留下遗言。随着加里被宣布死亡，聚集的证人中响起了掌声。有人喊道：“感谢耶稣。”约瑟芬娜·里维拉、丽莎·托马斯、艾格尼丝·亚当斯和杰基·阿斯金斯并不在其中。
As survivors of Gary's crimes, they weren't eligible to attend. Jackie celebrated the news of the execution surrounded by loved ones at home, telling reporters over the phone, "... I've been waiting 13 years for this." It was a sentiment shared by Deborah Dudley's sister, Carolyn, who witnessed the execution firsthand. It struck her that Gary's death was easy while Deborah had quote, died like a dog. Carolyn told reporters that with Gary gone, she felt like a burden had been lifted from her and her sister could finally be at peace. Sandra Lindsay's sister, Tracy, felt conflicted. One part of her felt relieved, like the chapter of their lives involving Gary Heiternick could finally be closed and she could focus on celebrating Sandra's life instead. Another part of her wished that Gary had been left to suffer in prison,
作为加里罪行的幸存者，她们没有资格参加。杰基在家中亲人的簇拥下庆祝了死刑执行的消息，并在电话中告诉记者：“……我等这一天等了13年。”黛博拉·达德利的姐姐卡罗琳也有同感，她亲眼目睹了死刑的执行。她感到加里的死太容易了，而黛博拉却是“像狗一样死去”。卡罗琳告诉记者，加里走了，她感觉卸下了一个重担，她的妹妹终于可以安息了。桑德拉·林赛的姐姐特蕾西感到矛盾。她的一部分感到如释重负，仿佛她们生活中涉及加里·海德尼克的那一章终于可以结束了，她可以专注于庆祝桑德拉的一生。另一部分她则希望加里能留在监狱里受苦，
where the women he'd killed would always be there to haunt him. Tracey hoped Gary's death would bring her family some sense of closure, but it wasn't that simple. Years later, Sandra's loved ones continued to grapple with what had happened, tormented by the details about how Sandra had died. As one outsider who attended the execution commented in an editorial to the Patriot News, Sandra Lindsay struggled to find her place in her complicated, confusing world. This was not just a crime against her or even our society. What Gary Heidenich did to her was, in my opinion, a crime against humanity. When the news first broke about Gary Heidenich's crimes and the extraordinary tale of the women's survival, one of the biggest questions was how could the neighbours have not heard or suspected anything?
在那里，他杀害的女性将永远萦绕在他心头。特蕾西希望加里的死能给她的家庭带来某种程度的了结，但事情并没有那么简单。多年后，桑德拉的亲人们继续与发生的事情作斗争，被桑德拉如何死亡的细节所折磨。正如一位参加死刑执行的局外人在《爱国者新闻》的社论中所评论的那样：“桑德拉·林赛努力在这个复杂、混乱的世界中寻找自己的位置。这不仅是对她或我们社会的犯罪。在我看来，加里·海德尼克对她所做的是反人类罪。”当加里·海德尼克的罪行和女性幸存的非凡故事首次曝光时，最大的问题之一是邻居们怎么可能什么都没听到或怀疑？
Deborah Dudley had spent the majority of her nearly three months in captivity screaming and fighting for her life. Members of the public couldn't help but wonder how nobody had heard the women screaming for help all that time. Gary's house shared a wall with a woman named Doris Zabuka. It turned out that Doris had once heard constant banging from next door. She thought it might have been Gary trying to get her attention, so she banged back. The noise then abruptly stopped. Doris later had the chance to ask the survivors why they didn't let her know they were trapped at that time. They explained they thought it was Gary banging back as some kind of test.
黛博拉·达德利在近三个月的囚禁中，大部分时间都在尖叫和为生命而战。公众不禁想知道，为什么这么长时间以来没有人听到这些女性呼救的尖叫声。加里的房子与一位名叫多丽丝·扎布卡的女士共用一堵墙。事实证明，多丽丝曾经听到隔壁传来持续的撞击声。她以为可能是加里想引起她的注意，所以她也敲了回去。噪音随后戛然而止。多丽丝后来有机会问幸存者，为什么她们当时没有让她知道她们被困住了。她们解释说，她们以为是加里在敲回去，作为某种测试。
Doris and other neighbours could offer no further explanation as to why they hadn't heard the women. Some had seen them enter the property and just assumed they'd left later in the night. Other locals told reporters that given all the drug dealing in the area, they'd learned to mind their own business. Gary even had other women visit the house during the period in question and none of them had heard or seen anything untoward. Even the officer who'd run a background check on Gary hadn't bothered to double check the spelling of his name or dig further to see whether the claims that he was dangerous were valid. The only thing that raised any questions
多丽丝和其他邻居无法提供进一步的解释，说明为什么她们没有听到这些女性的声音。有些人看到她们进入房产，只是以为她们当晚晚些时候离开了。其他当地人告诉记者，考虑到该地区所有的毒品交易，他们已经学会了少管闲事。加里在相关期间甚至还有其他女性来访，她们中没有人听到或看到任何异常。甚至那个对加里进行背景调查的警官，也没有费心去核对他名字的拼写，或者深入挖掘以查看他危险的说法是否属实。唯一引起疑问的事情
was the stench emanating from Gary's home in the days following Sandra Lindsay's death. Neighbours who knew of Gary's past suicide attempts were concerned that he might have killed himself, thus explaining the odour. An officer visited the premises to conduct a welfare check on Gary and had noted the overwhelming stench as well. Yet, even with Sandra Lindsay's family having reported their suspicion that Gary was involved in Sandra's disappearance, the officer accepted Gary's explanation that he'd just burnt a roast he planned on having for dinner. Had the police intervened then, they would have found Sandra's remains in the kitchen, and at the very least, Deborah Dudley's life would have been saved. For many, the reason this didn't happen is simple. One retired police commissioner
是桑德拉·林赛去世后几天从加里家中散发出的恶臭。知道加里过去自杀未遂的邻居们担心他可能自杀了，从而解释了这种气味。一名警官访问了该处所对加里进行福利检查，也注意到了那股令人窒息的恶臭。然而，即使桑德拉·林赛的家人报告了他们怀疑加里与桑德拉失踪有关，警官还是接受了加里的解释，说他只是烧焦了打算做晚餐的烤肉。如果警方当时介入，他们就会在厨房里发现桑德拉的遗骸，至少黛博拉·达德利的生命本可以被挽救。对许多人来说，这种情况没有发生的原因很简单。一位退休的警察局长
stated in the Monster Preacher documentary that Gary's behaviour was overlooked because he was a white male in an underprivileged neighbourhood who targeted women of colour. Gary's defence lawyer told the documentary's producers, I don't want to play the race card, but I have to say, the handwriting is on the wall in this case. The fact that Sandra Lindsay was from a poor black family who doesn't have any connections, I think that's what ended the investigation. You have good cops and bad cops and stupid cops and smart cops. We had a lazy and stupid cop, which was a lethal combination for Sandra." A retired detective who worked on the case added,
在《怪物传教士》纪录片中指出，加里的行为被忽视了，因为他是一个生活在贫困社区的白人男性，而他的目标是有色人种女性。加里的辩护律师告诉纪录片的制片人：“我不想打种族牌，但我不得不说，这个案子墙上写着字。桑德拉·林赛来自一个没有任何关系的贫穷黑人家庭，我认为这就是调查结束的原因。有好警察、坏警察、愚蠢的警察和聪明的警察。我们遇到了一个懒惰且愚蠢的警察，这对桑德拉来说是致命的组合。”一位参与此案的退休侦探补充道：
A retired detective who worked on the case added, If Gary Hydenick's victims had been middle class white women, everything would have been different. I think there would have been more help for these women, more organisations would have come forward to help them, and absolutely it would have been different. Irrespective of how they got there, they were still victims of a crime, and society needs to see them as that. Some have said that Gary Heidenich's crimes are up there with the most sadistic killers in American history. This was further solidified when it was revealed that he'd partly inspired the character of Buffalo Bill in the famous psychological thriller novel by Thomas Harris and the film by the same name, Silence of the Lambs. Buffalo Bill
一位参与此案的退休侦探补充道：“如果加里·海德尼克的受害者是中产阶级的白人女性，一切都会不同。我认为这些女性会得到更多的帮助，更多的组织会站出来帮助她们，绝对会不同。无论她们是如何到达那里的，她们仍然是犯罪的受害者，社会需要这样看待她们。”有人说，加里·海德尼克的罪行与美国历史上最残忍的杀手不相上下。当人们发现他部分启发了托马斯·哈里斯著名心理惊悚小说及其同名电影《沉默的羔羊》中的“野牛比尔”这一角色时，这一点得到了进一步的证实。野牛比尔
is the story's main antagonist, a serial killer who keeps his female victims in a well within his basement. Some still question whether Gary Hytennick really was sane enough to have been eligible for the death penalty, while others question his true motive. Whether he really did unknowingly force cannibalism on the surviving women also remains up for debate. When police recovered Sandra Lindsay's remains from Marshall Street, they also seized Gary's food processor and some other appliances. Despite the claims he'd made to Josefina Rivera about mixing parts of Sandra's body in with the dog food and feeding it to the others, testing of
是故事的主要反派，一个将女性受害者关在地下室水井里的连环杀手。有些人仍然怀疑加里·海德尼克是否真的理智到足以被判处死刑，而另一些人则质疑他真正的动机。他是否真的在不知情的情况下强迫幸存女性食人也仍有争议。当警方从马歇尔街找回桑德拉·林赛的遗骸时，他们还查获了加里的食品加工机和其他一些电器。尽管他曾向约瑟芬娜·里维拉声称将桑德拉身体的一部分混入狗粮并喂给其他人，但对
these appliances revealed no evidence to support this. While this didn't discount the possibility entirely, it meant there was no proof to support allegations of cannibalism. Whatever the truth, Gary was right about one thing. Although the death penalty remains in Pennsylvania and many inmates continue to sit on death row, no other prisoner has been executed since Gary in 1999. His lawyer doesn't believe that Gary's refusal to appeal had anything to do with making a political statement. He told reporters that Gary had erred by targeting black victims as he was, targeting black victims as he was, quote, getting his ass kicked every single day in jail. As far as his lawyer was concerned, Gary chose the death penalty to avoid a lifetime of beatings.
这些电器的测试显示没有证据支持这一点。虽然这并没有完全排除这种可能性，但这意味着没有证据支持食人的指控。无论真相如何，加里有一点是对的。尽管宾夕法尼亚州仍然保留死刑，许多囚犯继续坐在死囚牢房里，但自1999年加里之后，没有其他囚犯被处决。他的律师不认为加里拒绝上诉与发表政治声明有关。他告诉记者，加里因为针对黑人受害者而犯了错，因为他当时，引用：“在监狱里每天都被揍得屁滚尿流。”就他的律师而言，加里选择死刑是为了避免终身的殴打。
The basement at Gary Hytenick's former home on Marshall Street has been filled in, with the upper floors converted into apartments. But for the women who survived Gary's crimes, the psychological scars remain. Jackie Askins was just 18 years old when she was freed from the Marshall Street basement, weighing in at just 48 pounds, or roughly 20 kilos. She had to regain muscle and weight and learn how to walk again. All these years later, she can't bring herself to walk into a basement and she relies on various medications to help manage her anxiety, fear, and post-traumatic stress disorder. Jackie told Killer Profile that after they were freed, she wasn't given many tools to deal with the trauma. Instead, she said, "...you find a way in your heart,
加里·海德尼克在马歇尔街的前住所的地下室已经被填平，楼上被改造成了公寓。但对于在加里罪行中幸存下来的女性来说，心理创伤依然存在。杰基·阿斯金斯从马歇尔街地下室获救时年仅18岁，体重仅48磅，约合20公斤。她不得不重新锻炼肌肉、增加体重并重新学习走路。多年后的今天，她无法让自己走进地下室，并依靠各种药物来帮助控制焦虑、恐惧和创伤后应激障碍。杰基告诉《杀手档案》，她们获救后，并没有得到多少处理创伤的工具。相反，她说：“……你会在心里、
in your brain, to forget something that tremendous. It's like barricade it, hide it, so you can get on with your life. For the most part, you gotta be happy that you're free. In November 2020, 33 years after their escape, Jackie Askins and Josephina Rivera agreed to be reunited for the first time since Gary Heidenich's trial as part of Oxygen's Monster Preacher documentary. For all those years, Jackie still harboured resentment towards Josefina. That all changed when the women sat down and got to hash out their differing opinions for the first time. They both agreed that they should have had that conversation decades ago so they could have shared their healing journey together. Accepting Josefina's apology, Jackie said,
在大脑里找到一种方法，去忘记那种巨大的痛苦。就像把它封锁起来，藏起来，这样你才能继续生活。在很大程度上，你必须为自己自由了而感到高兴。”2020年11月，在她们逃脱33年后，杰基·阿斯金斯和约瑟芬娜·里维拉同意作为Oxygen频道《怪物传教士》纪录片的一部分，自加里·海德尼克审判以来首次重聚。多年来，杰基一直对约瑟芬娜怀有怨恨。当她们坐下来，第一次有机会梳理她们的不同意见时，一切都改变了。她们都同意，她们本应该在几十年前就进行那次谈话，这样她们就能一起分享治愈之旅。接受了约瑟芬娜的道歉，杰基说：
The person that should be apologizing to us is not here. She hoped they could move forward with a friendship given they were the only ones who could really understand what the other went through. Jackie said, Maybe that's what we're both missing out of our life. Each other. Josefina Rivera tries not to dwell on what happened to her, but it isn't easy. She eventually went through extensive therapy, beat her drug addiction, and reconnected with her children. She told Killer Profile that she considers it a win when she can go a whole day without thinking about the ordeal.
“那个应该向我们道歉的人不在这里。”她希望她们能建立友谊并向前看，因为她们是唯一能真正理解对方经历的人。杰基说：“也许这就是我们生活中所缺失的。彼此。”约瑟芬娜·里维拉尽量不去想发生在她身上的事，但这并不容易。她最终接受了广泛的治疗，克服了毒瘾，并与孩子们重新建立了联系。她告诉《杀手档案》，当她能一整天都不去想那段经历时，她就认为那是一次胜利。
That one good day can give her a light at the end of the tunnel. That one good day can give her a light at the end of the tunnel. For Josefina, a depressive episode can be triggered by something as small as seeing workmen digging in the road or laying eyes on a screwdriver or chain. She also struggles with the unwanted legacy of surviving the crimes. I'm never Josefina Rivera, she said. I'm always Heidenich victim, the Heidenich girl, the Heidenich this, the Heidenich that. It's not Josephina Rivera. It's never over. It's just never over. I can hear the explosions, I didn't know what was happening. I'm Vicki Petratus. And I'm Emily Webb. We are true crime authors and podcasters with a long history of interviewing people who've
那美好的一天能给她带来隧道尽头的光亮。那美好的一天能给她带来隧道尽头的光亮。对于约瑟芬娜来说，抑郁发作可能由一些小事触发，比如看到工人在路上挖掘，或者看到螺丝刀或链条。她还在与幸存者这一不受欢迎的遗产作斗争。“我从来不是约瑟芬娜·里维拉，”她说，“我总是海德尼克的受害者，海德尼克女孩，海德尼克这个，海德尼克那个。这不是约瑟芬娜·里维拉。它永远不会结束。它就是永远不会结束。”我能听到爆炸声，我不知道发生了什么。我是维基·佩特拉图斯。我是艾米丽·韦伯。我们是真实犯罪作家和播客主持人，有着长期采访那些
experienced unthinkable events. The next guy had this Molotov cocktail in his hand and I just saw him lighting it. Are you listening? Pay attention. Rithling Cafe. A gentleman has taken us hostage. He's got a gun and he's got a bomb. But he turned towards me
经历过不可思议事件的人的经验。下一个人手里拿着这个莫洛托夫鸡尾酒，我看到他点燃了它。你在听吗？注意听。Rithling咖啡馆。一位绅士劫持了我们。他有枪，还有炸弹。但他转向我
and he had this demonic look on his face and just came at me. These stories will have you on the edge of your seats. My shield man wasn't there anymore. It was me by myself. I had no protection. We are gonna die now. Who could get out of that situation?
脸上带着那种恶魔般的表情，直接向我冲来。这些故事会让你坐在座位边缘。我的盾牌手不在那里了。是我自己。我没有任何保护。我们现在要死了。谁能从那种情况下逃脱？
I could hear the explosions, I didn't know what was happening. It's just a matter of self-preservation to get myself out of there. We get to ask questions that most would never ask. And because of that we get told things most would never hear about. And I couldn't get my gun out, I'm sort of fighting with him. He's stabbing me. Maybe he just hit his head on the ground when he went down. Maybe he's okay.
我能听到爆炸声，我不知道发生了什么。这只是为了自保而离开那里。我们有机会问大多数人永远不会问的问题。正因为如此，我们被告知了大多数人永远不会听到的事情。我无法拔出枪，我正和他搏斗。他在刺我。也许他倒下时只是头撞到了地上。也许他没事。
I saw that she wasn't in a very good way. Yeah, this will be difficult for me to talk about. What draws us to these stories is the strength of the people coming out the other side of what they've been through. But it was eight years before I processed what happened in the siege. There is a way.
我看到她的情况不太好。是的，这对我来说很难谈论。吸引我们关注这些故事的是人们在经历过这一切后走出来的力量。但在我处理在围攻中发生的事情之前，已经过去了八年。是有办法的。
It's not going to be easy. You might have pitfalls, but you've got to keep going. I'm not going to let it beat me or defy me. So even though these are stories of the unthinkable, they are also stories of hope. You've got to be the best for you first before you can be the best for someone else. The unthinkable is available now. Be sure to download and follow The Unthinkable wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这并不容易。你可能会遇到陷阱，但你必须继续前进。我不会让它打败我或定义我。所以，尽管这些是不可思议的故事，但它们也是希望的故事。你必须先成为最好的自己，才能成为别人的最好。不可思议现在已经上线。请务必在您获取播客的任何地方下载并关注《不可思议》。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。